This is iPhone 7.
iPhone 7 Plus.
It makes all the things you do so much. Der Gospel ist über uns gekommen und er bringt uns frohe Botschaft aus dem fernen Wunderland, das da ist Kalifornien. Und es legt sich wie ein Sonnenstrahl über unsere Haut. Und wir fühlen uns gut, wir fühlen uns besser. Und das ist totally awesome. Wenn du die Kino schon nicht geguckt hast, Huckel, kannst du ja zumindest, also ich meine, du kannst ja...
Ja, wenn ich so ne Geschichten höre, wie da kriegt man gar keine Termine und so.
Ich weiß nicht, ob das mittlerweile überall so ist oder ob das ein Berliner Store ist, aber warum Apple noch keinen zweiten und dritten Apple Store aufgemacht hat in Berlin, verstehe ich nicht.
Also der Graves am Ernst-Reuter-Platz, der ist ja auch notorisch gut besucht im Service-Bereich, sagen wir mal. Aber bisher hatte ich da auch keine jetzt tagelang oder wochenlang Wartezeiten, sondern meistens kriegt man schon noch was am gleichen Tag, aber muss mittel warten.
Beim Apple Store ist es mittlerweile einfach, es gibt keine Termine, geh weg.
Nicht mal eine privatversicherte...
Keine Ahnung, ich brauch da so eine...
Aber ich bin auch privatversichert.
Ja, die Zeiten sind irgendwie vorbei, da war das irgendwie so früher, da hatten wir da so unsere kleinen Oasen.
Geht jetzt mehr kaputt oder gibt es einfach mehr Leute, die Apple geritten haben?
Es gibt einfach wahnsinnig viele Kunden. Das ist einfach das Problem. Von daher denke ich, dass Apple mit diesem Apple Store auch vollkommen überfordert ist. Also eine Region wie Berlin, was ja nicht nur Berlin abdeckt, sondern im Prinzip Brandenburg und wahrscheinlich auch noch Polen und was? Wo ist keiner? In der Summe schon. In der Summe hast du noch mal ein ganzes Berlin drum herum. Ja, wo sollen die sonst hinfahren zum Apple Store? Rostock?
Nach Rostock? Rostock fällt ja nicht mehr in die ICE, habe ich festgestellt. Das finde ich schon... Wahrscheinlich. Ganz ehrlich, wenn es eine ICE an die Ostsee gäbe, für...
Es gibt einen ICE, der einmal am Tag nach Usedom oder nach Streitsund fährt.
Ich wollte halt nach Rostock zu einem Konzert fahren.
Ja gut, da fährt er nur regional. Wo waren wir stehen geblieben?
Irgendwo da, Keynote so, mittendrin, Scroll mal ein bisschen.
Seit es mit der Uhr sind, wäre es eigentlich durch.
Man könnte nochmal ein wenig WatchOS thematisieren, vielleicht kurz.
Könnte man.
Ja, ich hab das jetzt installiert gestern und heute stelle ich fest, dass meine Uhr jetzt zur Sendung auf einmal auf 19% Akku runter ist. Das hatte ich vorher noch nicht. Normalerweise bin ich jetzt eher so bei 49 oder so was.
Ja, aber hast wahrscheinlich auch den ganzen Tag mit dem neuen OS rumgespielt und dir das alles angeguckt, wie das immer so ist.
Nichts mehr als sonst so. Also hat da andere Sachen zu tun. Hab heute schon mal gepodcastet, ein paar Stunden.
Schon, mit Holgi hab ich gehört.
Da ist man abgelenkt genug.
Das heißt, nachher um 11 machst du wieder schlapp?
Ich kann länger. Die Ente bleibt draußen.
So, was hast du denn noch bei der Watcher S3?
Kurz zur Watcher S3, vieles davon ist ja schon bekannt, aber muss sagen, es ist vom User-Interface her gut neu durchdacht worden. Sie haben wirklich mehrere Probleme auf einen Schlag gelöst, durch eine, wie ich finde, recht intelligente Umgestaltung der Bedienung. Also diese Idee, die Apps, die man oft benutzt, einfach in so einen Dock zu packen, wie man das ja eigentlich vom Rechner her konzeptionell auch schon kennt, die ist super. Und da die Dinger dann halt im Rahmen liegen, ist es halt auch schnell. Das war halt so ein Problem, dass die Sachen, die du oft benutzt, du hast halt so 2, 3, 4, 5 Sachen vielleicht, die du oft benutzen willst. Bei mir ist das so RunTastic, Musikkontrolle will ich haben. Will ich noch haben?
Twitter?
Nein, da bist du kein Twitter drauf. Also ich hab zwar Tweetbot, aber das ist nicht so die Anwendung, die du hier benutzt. Du benutzt so was wie ein Timer. Vielleicht willst du nochmal in den Nachrichten schauen. Find my friends gibt es jetzt auch auf der Uhr. Das finde ich auch super.
Das wäre nämlich tatsächlich auch mal meine Frage, wofür benutzt man jetzt, also du als Langzeitnutzer, diese Watch außer für Fitness-Tracking?
Also Notifications vor allem. Also einfach Nachrichten mitbekommen.
Aber ist das nicht dann auch Twitter-Notifications? Oder die machst du da nicht rauf?
Doch, doch, alles. Also eigentlich alle Notifications, die ich auf dem Telefon habe, leite ich mir auf die Uhr, außer Sachen, die mich nicht genug interessieren. Also das sind so ein paar Sachen. Da schalte ich dann aber tendenziell auch die Notifications auf dem Telefon aus, aber man kann das granular einstellen. Ich versuche das halt so weit runterzudampfen, bis es mich nicht mehr ausreichend nervt. Aber dadurch kriegst du halt Sachen gut mit. Ich meine, was weiß ich, bist du irgendwo so im Kino oder so, kriegst du eine Nachricht, machst kurz Tok Tok, drehst einfach mal kurz um, zack, unwichtig, weitergeguckt. Und nicht Handy aus der Tasche rauskramen, auch Unlock, Leucht, Strahl. Ja, das ist schon irgendwie ein ganz anderes Feeling, damit umzugehen. Ja, dann so kurze Sachen, so Timer, Stoppuhr hab ich häufiger mal im Einsatz. Da ist das auch wirklich ganz praktisch. Und dann natürlich wirklich für Sport. Also es ist einfach so als Fitness-Tracker, so als Starting Device. Ich ruf einfach Runtastic auf, sag ich, ich lauf jetzt los, fertig. Nicht irgendwie an der Uhr App starten, rumfummeln, User-Interface, Menüs durchhangeln, sondern einfach starten. Dann nimmt er auch sofort meinen Herzschlag direkt von der Uhr ab, speichert das alles mit ab, ist danach alles gesyncht, alles beep-bop.
Ich hätte noch eine Frage. Kann das Ding Navigation jetzt mit GPS, also kann man sagen, ich bin besoffen, wie komm ich nach Hause? Und dann sagst du dir, jetzt geh geradeaus erstmal und dann nach links und dann nach rechts?
Ja gut, aber das ist ja im Wesentlichen eine Anwendung des Phones, das heißt, das geht nicht ohne Phone.
Ja, das wäre...
Weil es hat ja kein Internet, also es hat ja kein LTE.
Na ja, gut, aber letztendlich, ja, gut, doch ein bisschen Map-Information brauchst du natürlich.
Ja, du brauchst halt die ganze Cloud mit den ganzen Daten und Verkehr und pipa-po, also das kommt ja da alles mit rein. Aber tatsächlich kann man halt sich ins Auto setzen, Doppelklick auf die Uhr machen und sagen, bring mich nach Hause.
Das hat ja bei mir einmal, das hat mich ja Siri zur Weißflug gebracht, dass ich wirklich so, das passiert mir selten, das Tee davor am liebsten ganz weit aus dem Fenster geschleudert hätte, hatte ich glaube ich schon mal erzählt, aber weil ich so, ja, rute mich nach Hause, was ist hier, ich will nach Hause, was auch immer, und dann, ich konnte dich leider nicht verstehen, aber ich könnte dir anbieten, dich nach Hause zu ruten, dann war ich so, okay, ja, was sag ich jetzt, sag ich jetzt ja, bitte, oder, dann hab ich einfach ja gesagt, und dann hat sie das aber auch nicht irgendwie richtig in den Kontext gekriegt und meinte, ja, also was willst du jetzt, wo möchtest du hin, und dann noch mal, ich will nach Hause, das hab ich leider nicht verstanden, aber ich könnte dir anbieten, dich nach Hause zu ruten, möchtest du nach Hause? Was? Das ging halt so dreimal hin und her, Ja, und da war ich wirklich so ok, ich hab's mal wieder probiert, naja.
Ja, wahrscheinlich können demnächst die Psychiater dich auch in solchen Fällen schlagen. Siri versteht mich nicht.
Ja, wirklich, was da für Psychosen oder Probleme entstehen können.
Ja, das ist es eigentlich im Wesentlichen. Einiges ist einfach schicker geworden mit diesen ganzen, wie man mit Ziffernblättern umgeht und so. Also man merkt auf jeden Fall, und das finde ich ja immer geil, Apple benutzt das auch. Also die benutzen ja ihre Sachen auch wirklich selber. Den Eindruck habe ich nicht unbedingt immer bei allen Zifferherstellern. Und sie haben sich da Mühe gegeben.
Hat ja auch eine Weile gedauert.
Haben sich Zeit gelassen, aber mussten...
Mussten sie erstmal auch finden, was die Leute mit der Uhr dann so machen. Was funktioniert und was nicht funktioniert.
Und sie haben ja auch, muss man ihnen ja auch anrechnen, es ist nicht so, dass sie jetzt sagen, oh, das war aber unsere ursprüngliche Idee, die müssen wir jetzt unbedingt auf Biegen und Brechen zum Sieg tragen, auch wenn es keinen interessiert. Sondern sie haben einfach Sachen komplett fallen gelassen. Sie haben diese Gold-Edition fallen gelassen.
Ja gut, das ist ja nur eine Gehäuse-Geschichte.
Das ist nicht nur, ja, das ist nicht nur eine Gehäuse-Geschichte, sondern es ist auch eine Art und Weise, wie sie ihr Produkt im Markt einfach platzieren und was ihr Selbstverständnis ist. Und was sie ja im Prinzip vom Start weg versucht haben, ist quasi so voll in diesen Luxusmarkt mit einzuhalten.
Das hätten sie natürlich gerne gehabt, aber ja. Was hätten die Leute jetzt gemacht mit ihrer goldenen Edition, nachdem der Inhalt irgendwie alt ist und die natürlich viel Geld bezahlt haben und dann aber so eine Uhr von vor 18 Monaten mit sich rumschleppen? Das will doch keiner für 10.000 Dollar.
Es gab doch dieses geile Foto beim Release von der Apple Watch von, wie heißt die noch, dieser deutsche Karl Lagerfeld. Der auf so einem Mode-Session, also Watch kam raus, Big Hype, la la la. Und dann haben sie halt so ein so Selected-Personalities, haben sie halt diese goldene Watch verteilt. Wahrscheinlich extra noch so ein Vogel von Apple da eingeflogen und hat ihm ganz offiziell irgendwie das Ding umgelegt. Aber zum Pairing ist es nicht gekommen. Und er lief dann auf diesem Event die ganze Zeit mit diesem Pairing-Screen irgendwie rum. Das ist natürlich auch so ein bisschen so, Johnny Ive is not amused. Ja, aber irgendwie Updates solide. Mal gucken, was das hier mit dem Akku ist. Das lässt sich jetzt, glaube ich, nach einem Tag noch nicht so richtig bewerten. Aber ich bin ganz zuversichtlich. Ob ich mir jetzt eine neue Uhr kaufe, weiß ich noch nicht so ganz genau. I'm tempted to do it. Mal schauen, vielleicht so. Einfach so als Kompensation. Ich warte mal die neue MacBook-Serie ab und dann gucke ich mal, wem ich mein nicht vorhandenes Geld nachwerfe.
Sehr schön.
Toll, toll, toll.
Ja, dann gab es noch neue iPhones.
Zum ersten Mal in dritter Generation unverändert, vom Gehäuse her, vom Style.
Dritte Generation? Du meinst, dass die Optik nicht total anders ist? Ich meine, sie hat sich ja schon geändert. Es ist ein anderer Formfaktor, der aber dem vorherigen sehr ähnelt.
Der Formfaktor ist schon ziemlich gleich. Was denn anders?
Na, die Rückseite, die Art und Weise, wie die Kamera eingefasst ist, ist anders.
Das war es aber auch wirklich.
Und das Finish ist anders. Und die Antennenverlauf ist anders.
Aber der Formfaktor ist der gleiche. Und die Hüllen, die passen nur deswegen, vielleicht nicht, weil die Linse der Kamera ist leicht verschoben im Gegensatz zum 6er. Aber ansonsten könnte man die gleiche Hülle nehmen. Das heißt, wenn man eine Hülle hat, wo das Loch groß genug ist, dann müsste das 7er da auch reinpassen. Und auch so vom Style, runde Ecken und so ist alles sehr gleich.
Also sie haben sich extrem bemüht, die offensichtliche Hässlichkeit dieser 6er-Serie weiterzuführen.
Ach so, du meinst die Antennen.
Nein, zu verbergen diese Antennen. Bei dem schwarzen ist das irgendwie ja...
Das war aber noch das geringste Problem. Ich finde eher, dass es so nicht... Also wenn ich es ohne Hülle benutze, dann habe ich immer Angst, dass es mir gleich abhauen wird und runterfällt. Das ist einfach zu glatt und slippy irgendwie. Ja, das ist nicht...
Das ist das Uncool.
Das war bei dem 5er nicht so. Das war wirklich angenehm ohne Hülle zu.
Du musst nicht sagen, ich habe mir einen SE gekauft.
Dann nehmen wir doch ein bisschen Sandpapier und raue die Oberfläche noch ein bisschen an.
Dann ist das Alu aber auch weg. Lass es doch so dünn.
Dafür gibt es ja nun diese ganzen Cover und Bim Bim. Ich finde, das sieht vor allem in dem Cover nicht so gut aus. Also gerade das SE.
Ja, aber es hält sich besser. Das Telefon sieht noch so gut aus, obwohl man es nicht sieht, weil ich einen Cover habe. Weil wenn ich keinen hätte, würde es schon gar nicht mehr gut aussehen. Weil es ja andauernd runterfällt.
Ist das jetzt ein 6S? Aber es gibt jetzt ein iPhone 7 und es hat irgendwie neue Farben und neue Innereien. Und ich muss auch sagen, ich finde, sie haben eine Menge getan an diesem Telefon. Also es sind schon doch nennenswerte Änderungen. Und teilweise, finde ich, marschieren sie auch irgendwie weiter, als man das jetzt so erwarten könnte.
Es gibt jetzt das in einer neuen, wie soll man sagen, neuen Farbe. Genau. Schwarz. Und das zweimal. Und zwar schwarz-schwarz und jet-schwarz. Und weißt du eigentlich, was jet-black heißt? Außer schwarz. Also wo das jet herkommt, was es heißt?
Hätte ich gesagt, nicht.
Wusste ich auch nicht. Hab ich mal gegoogelt. Weil es gibt irgendwie einen Song von weiß jetzt nicht mehr, wie es heißt. Kann ich gleich rausfinden. Aber da singt sie Call Me, nee, Paint Me Jet Black. Und dann dachte ich, was heißt das? Hat sie schwarze Haare oder was oder wie oder überhaupt? Jedenfalls dieses Jet, dieser schwarze Stein, dieser Feuerstein ist auch das falsche Wort. Aber es gibt so einen schwarzen Stein, der so sehr, so ein bisschen auch kwarzig aussieht, aber total schwarz ist. Der heißt wohl Jet. Und daher kommt das.
Das ist so ein...
Ein Stein, der so heißt.
Ja, oder ein Mineral vielleicht, oder weiß ich gar nicht, aber...
Wir schlagen nach...
Schlagt man nach, nicht, dass ich wieder Müll erzähle, aber... Joan as Policewoman, das war's genau.
Jett ist Kohle. Auf Deutsch Gargat, auch Jett oder Pechkohle genannt, ist durch Humusgel oder Bitumen impregniertes fossiles Holz, das sich in einem Übergangsstadion von der Braunkohle zur Steinkohle befindet.
Lag ich nicht ganz richtig, aber es war auf jeden Fall irgendwas mit Steinen, ja.
Auch Jett genannt.
Ja doch, das ist doch, aber schon guck, das ist schon...
Sieht aus wie ein iPhone, ne?
Trauerschmuck aus Gargat, okay, aber es ist schon ein Zeug, dass man sich auch um den Hals hängen kann. Ja, es gibt nämlich nicht nur die Flintstones, die da gerade sind, es gibt auch die Jetstones. Ja, aber daher kommt das Jetblack.
Jetzt kommt mal zu den...
Schwarzer Bernstein.
Jetzt kommen wir zu den Features, wo sie voran marschieren.
Ja, wo... marschieren sie denn voran? Also...
Eine wichtige Neuerung, wenn wir schon gerade beim Äußeren sind, ist, dass... Wir sind beim Äußeren, ne? Nur Äußerlichkeiten zählen. Also hat er ja schon erzählt, die Antennenlinien sind ein bisschen designmäßig woanders hingewandert. Du hast ja auch ein 6S, oder? Ne, beim 7er ist der Button hier kein Touchbutton mehr. Doch, ist es jetzt ein Touchbutton, das ist kein physikalischer mehr, sondern jetzt so ein logischer, könnte man sagen. Ob ich das so cool finde, weiß ich ehrlich gesagt nicht. Ich würde behaupten, ich hab's noch nicht probiert, ich würde behaupten, aber ne, wirklich gar nicht cool. Kann ich aber natürlich, ohne es probiert zu haben, nicht sagen, aber grundsätzlich sind so ne Move immer kacke.
Ich find's gut, weil mechanische Teile gehen kaputt. Also dieser Button, ich mein, mittlerweile haben sie es ja einigermaßen im Griff, aber der wird immer matschig nach einer Weile.
Und ich finde ihn vor allem zu laut. Meiner ist okay.
Ich finde ihn sogar ziemlich gut, im Gegensatz zu den älteren Phones.
Also beim 6S muss ich auch sagen, gefällt er mir eigentlich.
Vorher waren die teilweise schon immer so Klack, klack, klack, klack, das war mal ein bisschen nervig.
Das ist beim 6S nicht so?
Nee, ich fand das ist...
Naja, wenn du wirklich so richtig leise ist im Raum und du möchtest wirklich auf gar keinen Fall in irgendeiner Form auffallen, da ist so ein...
Halt mal ins Mikro.
Ah doch, guck. Das hört man schon. Also wenn es wirklich silent ist, dann...
Also man kann es auch leise machen.
Ja, mag leiser sein, ist auf jeden Fall etwas, was ich generell begrüße, dass da keine rein mechanischen... Also es ist ja immer noch mechanisch, weil sie haben ja diese Taptic Engine, die halt dann eben den Aktuator dort startet, aber den spürst du halt nur in deinem Finger, aber der wird knackhaft.
Und der Hand, die das Telefon festhält, natürlich auch.
Ja, aber es ist nicht akustisch, also es dringt mich akustisch von dem Telefon weg.
Außer wenn es auf der Tischplatte liegt.
Das mag sein, aber mir geht es halt wirklich so um dieses in einem dunklen Raum...
Grundsätzlich finde ich das ja auch cool, weil dadurch wird das Telefon ja auch wasserdicht. Das ist ja ein Faktor, der das wasserdicht macht. Aber ich erinnere mich an damals an einen iPod, der noch vorher das Clickwheel hatte, was man so drehen konnte. Ich fand das eigentlich ziemlich cool. Und dann haben sie ja auch dieses Touchwheel da gemacht und das ging gar nicht, das war Müll. Ich fand das Drehding super.
Ja, das Drehding, hast du es mal am Strand benutzt?
Stimmt, hat sie erzählt, dann war da ganz schnell Sand drin und so weiter. Aber welcher Nerd geht denn an den Strand? Sonde, Sand, Wasser, das will man gar nicht. Das ist nicht gut für meine Geräte.
Aber auf so ein Hippie-Hacker-Festival gehst du auch manchmal, habe ich gehört.
Ja, früher als ich noch jung war. Warst du eigentlich mit deiner, jetzt muss ich auch mal grätschen, mit deiner tollen DLC-Watch schon mal am Strand mit Sand und so und hat sie überlebt, ja?
Der Sand ist jetzt kleiner geworden.
Ja, also so Sandstaub, also auch so Gartenarbeit und die Uhr, das ist...
Kein Ding.
Nee, doch, das hatte tatsächlich kurzzeitig so Knirsch-Effekte in der...
Da sag ich ja, der Sand ist jetzt kaputt.
Der Sand ist jetzt kaputt, also es hat der Uhr null geschadet, nein. Also auch die Crown war so ein bisschen festge... Da dachte ich mir schon so, oh, oh, oh, aber es war dann kein Problem, man musste die nur so ein bisschen frei rotieren und irgendwann war auch gut.
Verstehe.
Aber das ist... Da bin ich jetzt auch zum...
Bist du vorsichtig.
Bandwechsler geworden, also ich gehe jetzt tatsächlich schon strategisch vor, welches Armband ich denn jetzt gerne am liebsten tragen würde.
Das heißt, du hast in deinem Rucksack, in deinem Emergency Case auch immer dein Notfallband bei?
Nee, das nicht, aber ich hab so morgens kann ich im Prinzip, hab ich so in meinem Bedschubkästchen, hab ich schon immer noch das andere.
Ja, heute wolltest du ja Gartenarbeit machen, bitte wechsel doch das Band, also weck dich die Uhr dann morgens schon.
Ich würde, wenn ich jetzt in den Garten fahre und da Umgrabungsarbeiten mache, dann würde ich halt, wenn ich dran denke, das Metallband vielleicht abmachen und genauso beim Laufen halt. Aber ansonsten bevorzuge ich halt das Metallband.
Tolle neue Welt!
First World Problems 200.
Genau, wir waren ja auch eigentlich beim iPhone mittlerweile schon. Darf ich mich noch mal kurz erinnern?
Ich hab ja auch gesagt, ich grätsche, so wie du das immer machst.
Du hast gegrätscht.
Hab ich ja angekündigt.
Also mit dem Homebutton, Leute meinen, es würde sich ganz anders anfühlen als vorher und es wäre eine Gewöhnungssache. Ich war nicht so begeistert. Ich kann mir vorstellen, dass man sich einfach dran gewöhnt, dass das dann eben so ist. Und ich würde es generell begrüßen, wenn das halt einfach leiser ist und wir müssen mal gucken, ob das irgendwie geil ist. Aber ich kann mir auch jetzt nicht vorstellen, dass ich es so schlimm gemacht habe.
Dein Touchpad klickt doch auch nur mit Taptic.
Ja, aber das ist schon was anderes, weil die Taptic Engine liegt ja nicht so direkt unter dem Button. Das ist ja nicht so, dass die dafür eine eigene Engine hat, die direkt da ist, sondern das ist halt da so, weißte, so ein bisschen so schräg mittelig.
Liegt denn die Taptic Engine direkt unter dem Button?
Nicht direkt da drunter, aber so halbkantig so.
Ist doch die gleiche wie dem 6S auch, oder? Die ist jetzt vielleicht ein bisschen anders geworden, aber ist das gleiche.
Das selbe Prinzip.
Das bestimmt jetzt noch akkurater und advanceder und stromspannender und kleiner und größer auch und leistungsstärker.
Vorgestern mit einem Spiele-Programmierer, der wollte mal wissen, wie das so ist mit diesem Feedback, weil er das für Spiele so interessant fand, wie man das so benutzen kann und der wollte wissen, ob man, egal wo man auf dem Display irgendwie drückt, ob man, also ob dieses Haptic-Feedback genau unter dem Finger dann kommt, habe ich mir gesagt, nee, das Gerät ist ja das, also das Device, das das macht, ist ja nur an einer Stelle und das ganze Telefon vibriert, aber du spürst das halt mit dem Finger, weil das halt die Stelle, wo man das Telefon berührt und dann fand das schon nicht mehr so cool.
Dann war die Excitement gone.
Ähm, okay und ja Water and Dust Resistant hat der Tim wieder aufgeschrieben, aber das hatten wir ja schon und es ist jetzt wasserdicht.
Das hat man nicht, die Uhr ist halt auf 50 Meter geeicht, aber das iPhone ist nur auf 1 Meter geeicht.
Aber schwimmen darf man jetzt schon, was wir vorher noch nicht so gesagt haben, jetzt darf man schon ein bisschen schwimmen.
Also wir meinen halt bis 1 Meter Tiefe, bis, was ist das, eine halbe Stunde, ähm, das ist diese IP67 Kategorie.
Ja die haben ja das Telefon vorher schon unter Wasser gesetzt, jetzt kann man es halt noch ein bisschen mehr unter Wasser setzen.
Genau, also wir haben jetzt halt überall so Seams dran und So ein Klounfall überlebt es jetzt schon mal.
Was auch, also wo sie jetzt mussten ja schon aus ein bisschen ummachen, das haben wir bei den äußeren Umbauten vergessen, weil ja jetzt die dreieinhalb Millimeter Klinke fehlt.
Du springst zu weit nach vorne oder wollen wir jetzt erstmal darüber reden? Aber ja, die Äußerlichkeit, also sie meinten ja, es wäre jetzt auch entsprechend staubresistent und vielleicht hilft das ja auch. Aber ja, du hast recht. Also wie wir hier auch schon mehrfach diskutiert haben und ich finde auch die Theorie, dass das alles ein Controlled League von Apple war, dass diese Information überhaupt in die Welt kommt, dass sich alle schon mal daran abarbeiten wollen, uns da nicht Schockwellen auslösen. Ja, sie haben das Ding jetzt irgendwie weggelassen. Und sie haben das Ganze vielleicht nicht so gut verkauft, wie man hätte können, ich finde, dass sie wenn man mal diese Entscheidung als solche so hinnimmt, dass sie es unter den Bedingungen ganz gut geregelt haben, indem sie halt diesen Adapter beilegen und ihn zum Nachkaufen auch nicht für 29 Euro raushauen, sondern zu einem Premium, das billigste Apple Produkt, was es jemals gab.
Für mich ist halt für mich ist ja also mein individuelles Problem mit dem Weglassen dieser Klinkenbuchse ist ja auch gar nicht mal unbedingt. Also ich höre ja schon keine Musik über das iPhone, weil mir diese Musik-App und so, das geht mir alles so auf den Zünder. Ich hab ein iPod Shuffle, diesen kleinen Quadratding, das ist der geilste Musik-Abspieler, den Apple gerade noch verkauft, weil User-Interface grandios einfach, beim Sport total unbehindern klippt man sich irgendwo hin, merkt man gar nicht, dass es da ist, hält lange genug mit seinen 2 GB und entsprechender Komprimierung der Musikdateien. Super! Also dieser Kopfhörer-Reinstöpsel-Hörbedarf, der ist damit schon für mich komplett abgedeckt. Ich stöpsel sehr selten Kopfhörer in mein iPhone rein. Aber Situationen, die ich sehr viel öfter erlebe, ist zum Beispiel im Proberaum, mal kurz was anspielen, entweder eine Aufnahme von Letztemal oder irgendeinen Song, den ich mal irgendwelchen anderen Leuten inspirativmäßig vorspiele, bei Partys, in der Bar, irgendjemand sagt, ey, hat irgendjemand Musik dabei und hält dir so eine Klinke hin und du stöpselst an und bist der DJ für die nächste Stunde.
Da hast du keinen Adapter dabei.
Und da habe ich einfach keinen Adapter dabei. Und ich, also, diese Situationen, kann man auch sagen, ja, passiert vielleicht einmal in der Woche, vielleicht einmal im Monat oder so, aber ich sehe schon, also hätte ich jetzt so ein Gerät, ich sehe diese Situation genau vor mir so, ja, warte, ich stecke das kurz an den Mikrofon. Hat irgendjemand einen Bluetooth-Adapter dabei?
Papa, die anderen wollen mich nicht beim Fußball mitspielen lassen. Ja, aber das passiert dir doch nur einmal die Woche.
Also nach wie vor...
Aber in Zukunft werden dann Leute so ein Ding dabei haben. Vor allem, wenn sie Musik machen.
Ja, ne, heutzutage ist es jetzt ja auch so, natürlich alle haben jetzt diese tollen, batteriebetriebenen Bluetooth-Bose und wie sie nicht alle heißen, Jam, Juke, Boxes und so weiter. Man braucht doch gar keine Stereo-Anlage mehr. Das geht doch alles so. Jetzt mit Bluetooth und Airplay und hast du nicht gesehen.
Also ich würde fast sogar behaupten, dass das Szenario, was du gerade beschrieben hast, wahrscheinlich ja das potentielle Nervigste ist. Weil das sind immer diese Momente, da ist man nicht darauf vorbereitet. Weil dieses Anschließen des eigenen Equipments, das ist eigentlich jetzt nicht wirklich so ein richtiges Problem. Wenn ich jetzt meinen Sennheiser HD25, den ich immer gerne nehme, benutzen will, mein Gott, dann ist da halt unten der Adapter dran, da ist ja Teil der Installation, bleibt da dran, fertig, okay, hat mich 9 Euro gekostet, ein Ding war dabei, scheiß drauf. Gut, kann man irgendwie verlieren, wird man auch, ist alles unangenehm und doof, so. Aber mein Gear kann ich halt in eine Konfiguration bringen, in dem es dauerhaft das Richtige tut. Und mittelfristig kommt das Gear vielleicht auch tatsächlich in so einer Lightning-Variante, wenn man denn nun wirklich ein Kabel benutzt. Das ist ja das andere Ding. Ich meine, was halt durchaus sein könnte, ist, dass man vielleicht so diesen kleinen Bluetooth- Audioadapter, den wir letztes Mal schon besprochen haben, dass man den einfach sozusagen mit dabei hat.
Ja, den muss man ja laden. Und dann ist der gerade, weißt du, dann hängst du deine Playlist an und hat jemand zufällig einen Mini-USB-Kabel. Okay, da könnte man noch Glück haben, aber weißt schon.
Ja, und das ist eigentlich auch das Hauptproblem, das ich hatte, das hatten wir ja auch schon vor ein paar Sendungen, glaube ich, auch mal rausgearbeitet. Also von Klinke auf was anderes zu wechseln, fände ich in dem Moment vollkommen unproblematisch, wenn klar ist, auf was. Aber jetzt sieht es ja so aus, als ob wir mit zwei solchen Stecker-Formaten weitermachen müssen. Weil der eine Teil der Welt, die ganze Android-Welt, wird halt nicht gleich ein Ding machen, sondern die werden auf USB-C gehen. Vielleicht sogar auch Apple mit ihren Laptops. Und nur die iPhones machen Lightning. Und das ist irgendwie so...
Ja, stimmt, daran hab ich auch noch nicht gedacht. Also du kaufst dir vielleicht einen Mac, kaufst dir dann noch einen Lightning-Adapter, damit du deine Beats irgendwie auch in deinem Rechner anstecken kannst.
Naja, das eigentliche Ding ist, dass Apple will, dass du Bluetooth benutzt. Also die wollen ja nicht, dass du diesen Adapter benutzt, die wollen ja eigentlich davon weg.
Ja, aber Kabel hat halt einfach gegenüber Bluetooth schon noch ein paar Vorteile. Die sind jetzt vielleicht auch nicht für alle Leute so relevant, aber diese Vorteile gibt es und sind Teil der Summe.
Das ist wie mit WLAN und Ethernet. Irgendwann...
Ja, ich mag es. Also erstens diese Laderei. Also dieses muss immer geladen sein. Und wie viele Geräte wirst du irgendwann mal geladen, alle immer geladen haben müssen, damit du einfach nur denselben Komfort hast, wie vor zehn Jahren mit deinem ganzen Equipment. Als alles noch nicht so advanced war. Und jetzt ist alles super advanced, aber es ist nicht mehr geladen. Geil. Und da können wir gleich nochmal über diese Airports reden. Da haben sie ja ganz interessante Antworten gefunden. Aber im Prinzip ist so diese Einfachheit, sehr klinke, natürlich auch irgendwie umgeschlagen. Und die wird natürlich auch nicht morgen verschwinden, sondern die wird auch nach den nächsten zehn Jahren überall dran sein.
Und gerade in so einer verransten Stadt wie Berlin, wo halt den Bars auch noch in zehn oder 15 Jahren so Platten-Spieler und alte Stereo-Anlagen, die Bar-Beschallungen machen und nicht irgendwelche tausend, was auch immer Euro-Anlagen, die schon Lightning und Bluetooth und hast du nicht gesehen haben. Also ich kenne auf jeden Fall genug Bars, die da garantiert noch sehr lange auf die Schallplatte und andere Abspieloptionen setzen werden. Also wo eine Klinke halt einfach immer noch der...
Ja gut, aber die Miniklinke spielt jetzt für Schallplattenspieler jetzt keine Rolle.
Aber ich weiß schon so, die Audio-Setups da...
Analog halt.
Analog!
Ja, aber...
Wer ist dieser Analog?
Aber dieses USB-C-Ding, also ich meine, jetzt haben sie halt auf dem Mac und auf dem iPhone noch, oder hatten sie bis vor kurzem, denselben Adapter für Audio und jetzt haben sie halt zwei verschiedene. Und ich sehe halt auch nicht, dass die MacBooks jetzt mit Lightning kommen.
Ja, dieser dreieinhalb Millimeter-Klinke kann aber trotzdem verschwinden.
Ja gut, also sie setzen halt irgendwie auf Bluetooth und sie sagen, das wird schon irgendwie alles gut, weil Wireless ist ja irgendwie besser. Wenn man sich jetzt mal diese Airpods anschaut, die sie jetzt noch dazu geliefert haben, die schon irgendwie ein kleines Meisterwerk sind, das muss man schon sagen.
Warum eigentlich?
Warum ich das finde, dass sie das sind? Naja, ich meine, das Ding ist einfach mega konsequent, indem sie einfach in die kleinen Teile wirklich sehr viele Sachen eingebaut haben, die ganz spezifische Probleme, die man bisher mit Wireless hatte, auch akut bekämpfen. Also erst mal, du hast kein Kabel dran. Also hast du auch keine Fernbedienung dran. So, Fernbedienung bei Bluetooth, wenn du einen großen Kopfhörer hast, ok, dann hast du genug Platz dafür. Wenn du aber jetzt wirklich nur so kleine Schnupsies im Ohr haben möchtest, das ist ja hier die Prämisse, musst du halt in irgendeiner Form ein Bedienungselement haben. Wie haben sie das gelöst? Mit einem Beschleunigungssensor. Das heißt, du tappst halt nur noch auf die Dinger. Sie merken einfach die Beschleunigung durch den Tap. Und ohne, dass du jetzt wirklich einen Knopf hast, sondern nur weil du die Dinger im Ohr hin und her bewegst, musst du dich dann draufhauen. Damit kannst du halt Pause und Call annehmen, machen und so weiter.
Das heißt, wenn mir einer aufs Ohr haut, dann geht auch gleich der Song weiter.
Na gut, wie oft haut dir jetzt einer aufs Ohr?
Über das Ohr vielleicht.
Wenn du so ein Ding im Ohr hast, dann kriegst du vielleicht öfter mal einen aufs Ohr gehauen. Wenn du nämlich nicht zuhörst, bang!
Na gut, das Problem hast du mit Kabel auch.
Aber da geht es nicht zum nächsten Song dann. Na gut, weiter.
So ist das. Dann haben sie so einen Infrarotsensor eingebaut. Das fand ich ja auch noch ganz lustig.
Das hat man ja gemerkt, wenn du es rausnimmst aus dem Ohr und der sofort aufhört zu spielen.
Genau. Und zwar, jetzt muss ich mir überlegen, ich hatte da was gelesen, wie sich das verhält. Also, du hörst jetzt Stereo. Jetzt nimmst du einen Ohrstöpsel raus, dann pausiert die Musik. Weil du sozusagen davon ausgehst, dass du, um mit jemandem zu reden, einen Ohrstöpsel rausnimmst. Und wenn du beide rausnimmst, dann anperrt sich das Ding auch sofort. Also nicht anperrt, sondern dann ist es nicht mehr das ausgewählte Audiodivise. Also wenn du beide rausnimmst, ist dein Telefon sofort wieder im Lautsprecher-Modus sozusagen. Auch wenn es dann vielleicht nicht gleich spielt. Aber wenn du dann Play machst, dann spielst du halt aus dem Lautsprecher. Und zwar ohne, dass du auswählst, anderes Teil, Disconnect, Bluetooth, Blark, Connect. Also diesen ganzen Hessel des Hin- und Herschalten, den haben sie an der Stelle schon mal ganz elegant abgefangen. Dann haben sie diesen unteren Kanal, diesen Seilstöpsel, ja auch noch benutzt. Da sind dann noch die Mikrofone drin. Das heißt, du hast auch noch zwei Mikrofone, nehmen also dein Signal quasi auch Stereofonen auf und nutzen meiner Erinnerung nach halt auch diese Mikrofone, um Außengeräusche irgendwie wahrzunehmen. Aber ich weiß nicht mehr so ganz genau, worauf das einen Einfluss hat, weil ein Noise-Cancellation haben sie ja nicht, oder? Das hab ich jetzt nicht mehr so ganz im Ohr, im wahrsten Sinne des Wortes. Und dann gab's irgendwie noch so eine Notiz aus einem Interview, wo halt auch so die Frage kam, naja, was ist denn beim Joggen und so? Fallen einem dann die Dinger nicht raus? Und da steht jetzt erstmal so die Behauptung im Raum, dass Leben wohl nicht so sei, weil...
Hab ich auch oft gelesen. Ich kann's mir ja noch nicht so richtig vorstellen.
Ein Argument ist, dass der Hauptgrund, dass hier die Ohrstöpsel aus den Ohren fallen...... sind die Kabel. Weil die ziehen da dran.
Da hat der Jogi einfach mal abgeschnitten zufällig und hat gemerkt, ey, das hält plötzlich.
Ich hab vorhin schon zu Tim gesagt, ich hatte noch nie so eine Hartplastik-Semi in ihren Kopfhörern, die in meinen Ohren gehalten hätten. Also die glibbern irgendwie alle raus. Also bei den... Ja, aber da gehört nicht viel zu. Also wenn ich so mache, also mit dem Kopf wackel, dann wackeln die einfach raus.
Ja, weil die Kabel ziehen.
Nein, weil meine Ohren irgendwie für diese Standard-Idee, wie ein Ohr aussieht, irgendwie abweichend genug sind. Und eigentlich die einzigen Kopfhörer, also in ihr sind die, die so eine weiche Gummi-Gnubbel vorne dran haben, die man halt so richtig so reinsetzt und dann bleibt es halt drin. Und deswegen...
Ach, oh Gott, da wurde gerade noch ein Link gepostet. Man kann die Dinger nicht lauter machen, außer über Siri zu gehen. Das ist nicht euer Ernst.
Wie, du kannst auch mit dem Plus-Minus-Button am Telefon drücken, oder nicht?
Ja, am Telefon, aber nicht... Normalerweise benutzt man ja die Lautstärke-Controlls am Kabel.
Wieso?
Bitte, das ist nicht euer Ernst. Das heißt, du kannst nur lauter und leiser machen, wenn du Internet hast. Du brauchst ja Internet, um diese Scheiß-Siri zu benutzen.
Nein, das ist Blödsinn da. Kann ich mir nicht vorstellen. Du kannst doch die lauter-leiser-Tasten benutzen.
Ja, aber dann musst du ja an dein Telefon ran. Ich meine, der Sinn von Wireless ist, dass du nicht an dein Telefon musst. Ich nehme alles zurück und behaupte das Gegenteil.
Also, wie gesagt, für mich auch wieder nicht relevant, es mag sein, dass 90% der Menschheit darauf gewartet hat, sich jetzt diese Gnubsis da ins Ohr zu stöpseln und Wireless und mit Charger Box, auf die man auch noch aufpassen muss und die man auch noch mal laden muss und so weiter.
Ja gut, das mit der Charger Box ist ja wiederum ganz elegant, weil du dann sozusagen auch immer geladene Dinger hast, ohne jetzt wieder ans nächste Kabel zu gehen. Also das finde ich schon einen ganz interessanten Ansatz. Aber diese Pairing-Technologie, die sie da drin haben, die ist recht charming, weil da haben sie sich jetzt ja nicht nur auf diese normale Bluetooth-Pair-and-Connect-Nummer, dieses zweistufige Ding verlassen, sondern sie haben halt so ein eigenes Pairing-Protokoll. Sprich, wenn du dann halt nur den Deckel von dieser Box aufmachst, dann ist bisher quasi schon, kriegst du ja schon so ein Verbindungsangebot. So mit User-Unterface und hier, und da hast du deine EarPods, die willst du anschließen. Soweit so gut. Machst du das einmal, bist ja dann auch gleich über iCloud quasi authentifiziert und kannst dann halt zwischen den Geräten hin und her schalten. Das heißt, es gibt einen Weg, ich weiß nicht ganz genau, wie man das auswählt, aber du kannst quasi schnell mal eben sagen, bitte jetzt mit dem Mac, jetzt Laptop, jetzt iPhone, hin und her schalten, alles gut. Dass diese EarPods selber vielleicht nicht die richtige Wahl sind, geschenkt, gibt ja jetzt auch noch drei andere Varianten, die sie unter dem anderen Label rausbringen, nämlich Beats. Also das heißt, es gibt sozusagen einfach nochmal einen Knochen-Kopfhörer und es gibt nochmal so was weiß ich so komische Sport- ums Ohr-Legeteile und auch eine Variante. Und die haben ja dann auch irgendwie entsprechende Controls.
Ja, wie gesagt, ich fühl dann die 90 Prozent da draußen. Für mich ist das nix. Also ich hab's auch nicht eilig. Jetzt wo ich gesehen hab, dass Bayer Dynamik den DT1990 Pro rausgebracht hat, spare ich schon fleißig lieber dafür.
Was ist das?
Das ist quasi der 990 Pro mit ihren neuen Tesla Treibern und Super Linear und so weiter. Also Referenzklasse Studio Kopfhörer TM. Also es gibt ja den 1770 Pro schon mit diesen Tesla Treibern und jetzt haben sie den 1099. Der ist halt offener oder halb offen und der 1770er oder 1770er ist ja der geschlossene.
1.990 pro für schlappe 600 Euro.
Ja, aber kommt halt auch, also das ist so Biodynamic Plus Plus Deluxe de la Cac Ausstattung. Den hätte ich schon ganz gerne, aber ich warte vielleicht auch noch ein bisschen, bis vielleicht da in der Einführungspreis nochmal ein bisschen absagt.
Einseitig geführtes steckbares Kabel mit Mini XLR Anschluss. An welcher Stelle?
Am Hörer selbst, wenn ich das richtig...
Mini XLR am Kopfhörer? Auch ein Tesla macht jetzt auch Kopfhörer.
Das sind ihre selbst entwickelten neuen Special Plus Plus Deluxe Treiber mit super dünnem Draht und damit, also Höhledynamik und irgendwie haben sie zwei unterschiedliche Polster oder Ohrmuscheln und eine ist halt so ein bisschen mehr Hi-Fi und eine ist halt super linearer Frequenzgang für Studio. Und die sehen auch auf den Bildern, wenn du dir den mal so in groß anguckst, also das ist so wirklich so Hardware-Porn. Also ich meine die Biodynamik Sachen sind eh alle super gut verarbeitet, aber die ersten Testberichte, die lesen sich dann auch so wie das Ding hast du einfach dein ganzes Leben.
Beim Mini XLR als Kopfhörerstecker, das finde ich ja mal geil.
Ja, ist eine super Idee, finde ich auch.
Ja, das ist eine super Idee. Das könnt ihr sich mal durchsetzen bitte.
Also bisher haben die Kopfhörer ja, so meiner zumindest, hat an der Stelle eine 2,5 mm Klinke.
Wobei ich bräuchte Mini 5x XLR.
Für das Headset dann sozusagen. Ja, das gibt es ja auch. Das fände ich wirklich sehr begrüßenswert, wenn sich das auch durchsetzt. Genau, und dann gibt es wie gesagt auch den 1770 Pro, das wäre dann die geschlossene Variante. Im Chat wird behauptet, die AKGs hätten das mit 5-fach Mini XLR. Aber das ist halt AKG. Sagt hier jemand im Chat, das ist jetzt ungeprüft. Ganz unten, du bist schon wieder einen halben Kilometer hinterher mit dem Scrollen.
Ja, es scrollt immer nicht, wenn man da nachguckt. Die AKGs, was man das heißen mag.
Naja, das als kleine Themenblutgerätchen wieder dazwischen. Ich glaube, die Headset haben sie noch nicht mit dem Tausenderpräfix versehen. Du wählerst. Ecke? Einer im Chat sagt sogar, also hier der AKG Q701 für Ohrenschmaus im Studio. Aber ich muss sagen, ich bin mit den Biodynamik schon vollkommen zufrieden.
Premium Quincy Jones Signature Line Over Ear.
Was hat denn der arme Quincy Jones damit zu tun?
Weiß ich auch nicht. Ach, so typisch AKG Design. Das ist doch nur Kopfhörer, das ist doch keine Headset. So, irgendjemand meinte, wir hätten schon genug über Apple geredet. Aber das ist doch nur ein Troll.
Aber das war nicht der Fall, genau.
Weiter geht's.
Jetzt erst recht.
Ich hab ja mal ein Bier, ne?
Dann haben wir von den Äußerlichkeiten an dem iPhone alles durch, oder? Oder muss man die Kamera als Äußerlichkeit sehen? Eigentlich schon, ne?
Weiß ich nicht, die Innerlichkeiten könnte man ja auch nochmal...
Ja, da kommen wir ja dann gleich zu, wenn wir die Äußerlichkeiten durchhaben. Also ich würd sagen, Hardware zuerst, oder?
Ich weiß nicht genau, worauf du jetzt hinausfällst.
Weiß ich auch noch nicht.
Na, wir könnten nochmal diese Prozessor-Frage...
Ja, ich hab da ein bisschen gegoogelt.
Die Benchmarks von diesem iPhone 7 sind ja Awesome Source, also... Das Ding macht irgendwie Geekbench, 3.200 und ein paar zerquetschte. Das ist richtig schnell. Also das iPhone 7 ist jetzt auf jeden Fall mal rassig viel schneller als das MacBook.
Aber das war ja bei jedem iPhone, was rauskam, also war einfach mal...
Das iPhone 6S war das erste, was im Integer, im Single-Core-Score das MacBook eingeholt hat. Und das iPhone 7 holt es jetzt auch, glaube ich, im Multi-Core mit ein. Und das ist schon wirklich ziemlich schnell. Also vor allem haben die ja... Ich meine, wenn die ja, die haben ja immer diese nette Grafik, den kann man jetzt glauben oder nicht, aber wenn man die Geekbench-Zahlen so folgt, haut das, glaube ich, halbwegs hin. Das ist so dieses Fick dich, Moore-Grafik, wo sie einfach sagen, wir haben ja mal exponentielle Steigerungen Jahr für Jahr, sowohl im GPU-Bereich, als auch im CPU-Bereich. Und die werden halt nicht nur schneller, sondern sie werden immer schneller, schneller. Also schon so ein bisschen wie das Universum. Und das finde ich schon ziemlich bemerkenswert. Also die Dinge, die man mittlerweile auf diesen Geräten machen kann, das ist halt etwas, was bis vor kurzem noch eben nur in der Laptop-Klasse möglich war. Also die sind jetzt nur noch wenige Jahre hinterher. Je nachdem, welche Geräteklasse man jetzt eben vergleichen möchte, bis hin zu sind schon da.
Also der Single-Core von so einem iPhone 7 hier, ja. Single-Core jetzt. Hat mehr Bums als der Prozessor an unserem Mac Pro. Das heißt, der hätte es den iPhone 7 kaufen sollen. Also drei dann natürlich, aber...
Ja, aber das ist ja, also nicht alles, was hängt, ist ein Vergleich. Weil mit so einem Telefon kann ich halt nicht die gleichen Sachen machen.
Schon klar, aber das muss man sich von der Leistung ja mal vorstellen.
Was ist denn der Geekbench-Score von uns abends?
Es gibt ja ein neues Geekbench, falls die Leute noch...
Geekbench 4, ja.
Ja, Geekbench 4, das ist ganz cool.
Muss man das kaufen?
Nö, muss man nicht. Das iPhone 7 hat hier einen Single-Core-Score von 3242 natürlich. Und ich glaube hier so dieser Xeon W3680, den wir haben mit 3,3 Gigahertz, hat so um die 3000 oder so oder 3100. Also er ist knapp drunter. Das ist schon ein bisschen ärgerlich. Vor allem schaffen die das mit, weiß nicht, mit was? Mit 2,3 Gigahertz. Also es ist schon krass, was man da so mit sich rum schleppt. Klar, es hat nicht so viel Speicheranbindung. Na doch, AES Support hat es sogar. Hat viele andere Sachen nicht vielleicht, aber so grundsätzlich. Ich warte, bis die das wirklich mal in so eine Hut, also in ein MacBook oder sonst wie einbauen.
Was ist Mac Pro?
Der ist jetzt hier nicht mit drin, weil das sind ja nur die Telefone. Aber der Mac Pro wäre dann, also hier 3200, der Mac Pro, den wir haben, der wäre dann, also 2009er, also wir sind jetzt bei Single Core genau, der ist ja irgendwo hier unten bei 3000, hier ist einer genau, der 2950, der 2010er, ja.
Aber die Original-CPU oder die?
Nee, schon fast die schnellste davon.
Ja, was ist denn das erste, welche Macs überholen das Ding noch? Das überholt ja hier noch so einiges mehr.
Na, das gucken wir mal, also das war 3242, ne?
Ja.
In dem Bereich liegt hier das MacBook Pro, 13 Zoll von Mitte 2014, das ist ein Stück schneller.
Mein MacBook Air.
Und MacBook Air von 2015 ist schon minimal langsamer.
Aber was benchmarkt der?
Ein MacBook Air vom letzten Jahr...
Ja, so lauter Zeugs, also es ist nicht nur...
Ein MacBook Air vom letzten Jahr ist minimal langsamer als das iPhone dieses Jahr.
Kann aber trotzdem mehr.
Ist ja ein synthetischer Benchmark. Also die testet ja auch nur hier...
Kann auch weniger.
Kleine Schleifen, also so ein Laptop muss ja drum rum schon noch ein bisschen mehr machen.
Mehr Speicher, mehr Display.
Ich würde sagen, bei GPU ist das iPhone, dem er aber wahrscheinlich noch mal sehr viel mehr überlegen.
Wir werden das sehen, wenn Apple demnächst, wie gesagt, ihre A10, A11 oder worum auch mal Prozessoren, dann mal in so einem Desktop einbaut.
Was meins denn muss mehr machen? Ich meine, das Telefon muss mittlerweile auch eine Menge machen.
Allerdings sind ja auch viele Subsysteme sozusagen gekapselt. Also zum Beispiel diese ganze Gyro-Axelerometer-Kram. Also früher war das halt so, du hattest so einzelne Chips. Und die musstest du dann halt selber mit deinen Bitpatterns anklopfen und die Daten da rauspopeln und parsen und verarbeiten. Mittlerweile kriegst du halt so die Packages komplett mit Gyro, Kompass und haste nicht gesehen. Und kriegst das quasi als AP über den Bus nur noch angeboten und musst gar nicht mehr sozusagen selber in der CPU oder in deinem OS oder was auch immer da groß rumhantieren. Also diese Subsysteme, die werden halt auch immer mehr sozusagen gekapselt, sodass dann für die CPU selber da gar nicht mehr so viel zu tun ist. Oder das OS, wie auch immer.
Die haben da glaube ich eh nicht so viel zu tun.
Ich meine nur, weil du meinest ja, das Telefon hat auch eine ganze Menge zu tun.
Nee, im Sinne von es muss ja da irgendwie Baseband und im Hintergrund tun sich ja mittlerweile auch da Dinge, da muss die ganze Zeit Verbindungen offengehalten werden, Push-Notifications empfangen werden. Also es ist nicht so, dass keiner da Aktivität hätte. Und da ist so ein R... Du musst sowas halt nicht machen. Aber halt mir einfach mal nur fest, die CPU-Entwicklung auf armen Basis, die sie jetzt im Rahmen dieser iPhone-Entwicklung losgetreten haben, ist mittlerweile mit einem Gerät, was deutlich weniger Strom verbraucht als so ein MacBook, performancemäßig rangekommen. Und es lässt sich gut ausrechnen. Also angenommen, du würdest jetzt so einen A10-Prozessor mal bauen mit denselben Stromversorgungseinheiten und Batterien, wie das Air es hat. Also wenn du da jetzt mit einer Air-Batterie und externem Strom rangehst, aber nur dieselbe Technologie benutzt, um irgendwie die Performance abzufeiern, da bleibt das Ding doch irgendwie im Schlick zurück. Also ich meine, die könnten da noch mehr aufdrehen.
Vor allem müssten dann auch die teure CPU bei Intel kaufen, weil die kosten bestimmt ein paar Dollars mehr als das, was die da selber bauen.
Eben.
Das ist ja der ultimative Apple-Traum von Hard- und Software aus einer Hand, wenn sie die CPU halt kaufen.
Aber der Fortschritt wird sich da jetzt auch verlangsamen, weil bei den Nanometers, da ist ja Apple jetzt auch am Ende, sind ja schon letztes Jahr beim 6er waren es 16 Nanometer. Ich weiß nicht, wie viel sie dieses Jahr haben, ob das schon die 14 sind. Nee, letztes Jahr waren sie bei 14 schon.
Jetzt sind sie immer noch bei 14. Da wollen sie wohl auf 10.
Ja, wenn es das dann schon gibt und so.
Ich kann mich da jetzt nur so auf die allgemeine Gerüchteküche...
Bist du dir sicher, dass letztes Jahr auch schon 14 waren, nicht 16? Mach dir das mal weiter.
Ach so, ja. Performance. Also da steckt schon eine Menge drin und ich finde das bemerkenswert. Und wir werden da sicherlich noch eine ganze Menge sehen, was da noch so kommt. Und für Auswirkungen hat. Du meinst gerade diese Nummer mit dem Doppelchor ist irgendwie nichts Neues?
Also die haben ja gesagt, dass die im iPhone, dass es ein Quadchor ist, erstmal so, dass er vier Kerne hat, so haben sie es gesagt, also ist ja Quadchor. Aber dass davon halt die, da sind, von den vier Kernen sind zwei langsam getaktet oder sehr stromsparend. Und zwei sind halt für Performance ausgelegt und er wechselt je nach Bedarf irgendwie darum. Das heißt, die vier sind nie gleichzeitig aktiv. Und der Gruber hat in seinem Blog geschrieben, dass das ja was wäre, was es vorher so noch nie gegeben hätte und dass das dazu beiträgt, dass die Batterie da länger hält bei dem iPhone 7. Ich bin aber der Meinung, dass ich schon vor Jahren, also zwei, drei oder wann auch immer das war, gelesen hab, dass diese Snapdragons, die Samsung da benutzt, weil die hatten ja auch schon vor drei Jahren sagen wir mal irgendwie so ein Quadchor und da haben die das eigentlich schon genau das Gleiche gemacht. Und die haben das marketingmäßig natürlich auch so gesagt, ja wir haben ja ein Quadchor. Und haben aber nur im Kleingedruckten erwähnt, dass es eigentlich zwei für Performance und zwei sind zum Stromsparen und dass die nicht gleichzeitig zum Einsatz kommen. Und dann ist das wohl die gleiche Technik wie das, was Apple jetzt macht. Deswegen ist es also nichts Neues. Ich hab jetzt irgendwie nachgegoogelt, hab jetzt aber diesen Beweis für diese Snapdragons. Vielleicht waren es auch nicht Snapdragons oder irgendwelche anderen, die Samsung eingesetzt hat. Aber es war auf jeden Fall ein Android-Telefon, das irgendwie Quad-Q hat. Und ich glaube, auch jetzt gibt es ja irgendwie Octocore von denen, richtig? Und ich glaube, da machen die das auch genauso, weil ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, was man mit Octocores in einem Telefon soll.
Niemand braucht Octocores im Telefon.
Also dieser Galaxy S7, ist das dasselbe? Ich blicke da nicht durch. Also hier ist davon die Rede, dass diese 8 Kerne irgendwie 2 können sich besonders hochtakten oder abschalten. Aber das ist ja nicht so ganz dasselbe, wenn ich das richtig sehe. Ja gut, wie auch immer. Also ob das jetzt das erste ist oder nicht, da will ich mich gar nicht einmischen. Auf jeden Fall ist es ganz interessant, dass sie halt auch weiterhin sich quasi so CPU Designs zusammen stecken, die einfach genau für diesen Bereich irgendwie auch gedacht sind. Das ist schon irgendwie echt gar nicht so blöd. Kannst du ruhig machen, my dream. Ja, gut, sehr viel gibt es da nicht zu sagen. Ich hoffe, es ist einer. Achso, wir haben ja noch, was haben wir noch vergessen? Die Kamera, ich weiß nicht, wann wir über die Kamera reden. Man kann über die Kamera...
Besser, schneller, geiler.
Ja, ist irgendwie toll, hat Zoom.
Naja, also was jetzt neu ist bei der Kamera ist, dass sie erstens den Image-Stabilisator hat, also das kleine ohne Plus, weil bei dem 6er und 6s hatten nur die Plus-Version diesen Image-Stabilisator und und zwar das 6s Plus auch dann für Video, das 6er Plus noch nicht für Video. Also sie haben das dann so graduell verbessert. Aber jetzt gibt es diesen Image-Stabilisator auch für die normale ohne Plus-Variante. Das ist eigentlich schon interessant, weil sorgt... Ja, stand da bei dem Gruber, der hatte einen längeren Artikel da. Und das andere noch was Interessantes ist, dass sie die Blende von, was war es, von 2,2 auf 1,8 irgendwie vergrößert haben. Dacht man das so? Ich weiß nicht. Also die Öffnung ist auf jeden Fall größer.
Die Zahl wird kleiner, aber die Blende wird größer. Kommt mehr Licht rein, 60 Prozent.
Genau, das heißt kann man auch im Dunkeln, kriegt man dadurch jetzt noch bessere Bilder hin. Und das ist schon auch nicht so schlecht.
Sie haben da eine ganze Menge an Kleinigkeiten mit eingebaut. Das ist immer so Optimierung, an die man vielleicht auch gar nicht denkt. So ein Flickersensor, das automatisch 50 Hertz flackert in einer Leuchtstoffbröre zum Beispiel. Was war das denn jetzt?
Ich hab jetzt gedrückt oder ist das Ding nicht aktiviert?
Du hast es nie getestet, dein Akku ist wahrscheinlich alle.
Dieses Wireless, das ist aber eine Freude.
Geht's noch mal? Geht doch. Du musst es auch einschalten vorher. Jetzt bin ich fertig mit Husten. Kaum macht man es richtig.
Das war eine sehr schöne Wireless-Demonstration.
Das ist noch Bluetooth 0.5, anstatt 5.0.
Ja, 0.5 ist es nicht.
Aber es ist schon ein bisschen älter, ne?
Die Remotes, ich weiß gar nicht, welchen Bluetooth-Standard die machen.
Sie ist zu alt.
Aber wahrscheinlich nicht Bluetooth 4, sonst würden die auch das länger halten.
So, was hast du gesagt, Flickermodus? Ja, das ist dann interessant, wenn man weiß, dass bestimmte Lampen hier, ich weiß, LEDs gehören jetzt wahrscheinlich nicht mehr dazu, aber früher so, dass die halt auch bei diesen 50 Hertz Leitungsflimmern haben. Und wenn das die davon natürlich, so die Helligkeit misst, gerade dann, wenn die Lampe an ist und das Bild entschießt, während die Lampe aus ist, dann stimmt das wahrscheinlich alles nicht und dann kriegst du da irgendwie ein doofes Bild. Und beim Video sieht es sowieso immer scheiße aus, besonders wenn man Aufnahmen mit 120 Frames die Sekunde macht, oder sogar 240. Und da haben sie jetzt wohl rausgefunden, dass sie das so mitmessen und dann wahrscheinlich genau in einer hellen Situation das Bild schießen und nicht in der Dunkelheit. Das ist schon gar nicht so schlecht.
Also der ganze Voodoo, den sie da erklärt haben, was sie da alles für Optimierungen machen und wie viele Bilder sie da zwischendurch aufnehmen, um irgendwie ein einziges Bild zu machen, da platzt einem ja irgendwie das Hirn. Also diese ganze Kameraabteilung von Apple, die ist an sich schon mal so ein eigenes Fortune 500 Unternehmen wert. Das ist einfach enorm. Man muss ja auch mal sehen, dass es die mit Abstand meist benutzte Kamera der Welt.
Ja, ich wollte ja letztes Mal auch eigentlich ein Accessoire aus erster Benutzerhand quasi anpreisen, was ich für mein iPhone gekauft habe und im Urlaub verwendet habe und was ich jetzt wahrscheinlich fürs iPhone 7 neu kaufen müsste, weil die Kameraposition sich leicht verändert hat. Was denn?
So ein Clip-On-Teil.
So ein Clip-On-Teil, den Ollo Clip heißt der. Ollo Clip hat ein Fischeye und einen Weitwinkelobjektiv und man kann die Linsen abschrauben und Makro- und Supermakro- Aufnahmen damit machen. Ich war immer sehr skeptisch mit diesem Clip-On-Lenses, aber ich muss sagen, das funktioniert echt erstaunlich gut. Wie klebt man die dann drauf? Du hast das noch nie in der Hand gehabt. Probier mal, das da drauf zu stecken. Das ist wirklich erstaunlich intuitiv und funktioniert zuverlässig. Man muss nicht groß hin und her schieben oder so, die haben das wirklich ziemlich geil designt. Eigentlich schiebst du es von oben drauf.
Von oben?
Selbstständnis keines im fünften Ansatz.
Es ist ziemlich idiotensicher.
Es ist ja schon drauf. Von oben habe ich jetzt von der Seite, aber von oben ist es auch ganz easy. Dann schiebt man es zur Seite und dann sitzt es auch. Dann nehme ich hier den Deckel ab und gehe in meine App.
Du hast krass Weitwinkel am Start.
Und da oben war.
Da habe ich ja gar nichts am Start.
Achso, man muss doch nach da schieben.
Okay, jetzt.
Und ohne hätte ich... Ja, alles klar.
Das ist jetzt nur das Weitwinkel. Das Fischei ist halt richtig krass.
Ja, so ist es jetzt so.
Und sonst wäre es so. Was ich richtig beeindruckend fand, waren die Makroaufnahmen. Weil ich dachte erst so, okay, du schraubst die Linse ab, um Makro zu kriegen. Und es funktioniert erstaunlich gut. Also du kannst wirklich super nah rangehen und da den Teil aufnehmen.
Könntest du hier so ein Meter eben ein Foto machen?
Das wäre der Tim nicht, ne?
Ach, die Privatsphäre.
Ja, das wissen doch eh schon alle. Stehen da wieder 50 Leute vor der Tür. Wie immer.
Lass einfach das Geld da liegen und haut ab.
Also, ja, ich hab einen Kollegen, der früher so, also der auch immer noch mit richtigen Fotokameras arbeitet und Fotoginalist war und der benutzt halt aber auch ganz oft auf Reisen einfach nur so eine Clip-on-Lens und der hatte die und hat mir die dann in der zweiten Urlaubswoche überlassen, damit ich damit mal rumspielen kann. Und das hat mir so viel Spaß gemacht, dass ich mir dann gleich nach dem Urlaub selber eine klicken musste. Ich glaub 49 Euro.
Also man denkt jetzt beim ersten Mal, wo man den so sieht, bei dir alles klar, es ist alles so billig, billig, Pliste, Pliste, aber ich hab mal gerade gehuckt, die sind irgendwie sogar entspiegelt, hab ich das Gefühl, die Gläser.
Ja, so.
Also irgendwie, die machen nicht so den richtigen ultraspiegeligen Eindruck. Also irgendwie haben die da was getan. Also es ist nicht not too shabby.
Not too shabby, genau. Also es ist der Fotomensch, der hat sich natürlich auch entsprechend belesen. Es gibt bestimmt Clip-on-Lenses, die noch krasserer sind, aber für das Preis-Leistungs-Verhältnis sind die halt wirklich ganz vorne mit dabei. Die haben bestimmt auch noch andere im Angebot. Aber ja, wie gesagt, ich kann das empfehlen, weil gerade die normale iPhone-Optik, die ist halt okay, aber es gibt Situationen immer mal wieder, wo man denkt, ich hätte jetzt gerne mehr drauf oder irgendwie passt dann doch nicht so ganz. Und mit diesen Wechsel-Lenses kommt sofort der Fotospass wieder zurück. Es ist nicht nur so eine einfach Point-and-Click, ich kümmere mich jetzt eh nicht ums Bild. Sobald du so ein bisschen Varianzen noch bei den Linsen hast, ist sofort so mein Fotografiergeist wieder erwacht und hatte dann ganz viel Spaß.
Das ist diese Four-in-One-Lens.
Ach, dann ist die sogar... Okay, auf der Webseite kostet es 79, weiß gar nicht. Habe ich die bei Amazon billiger bekommen?
Also es gibt hier eine Active-Lens und eine Four-in-One. Oder welche ist denn das jetzt?
Ich habe die Four-in-One, weil die hat ja eben Weitwinkel und Fischei und dann hast du einen Super-Macro, wenn du die abschraubst. Fand ich gut. Also da profitiert sicherlich das iPhone 7 auch davon.
Na gut, die beste Kamera ist immer die, die man dabei hat. Aber für Leute, die jetzt auch das iPhone gezielt in verschiedenen Situationen benutzen, mag das eine ganz interessante Option sein.
Ja, also es macht vor allen Dingen, wie gesagt, Spaß. Und wenn man dann gerade auf Reisen ist und so ein bisschen auch das fotografisch dokumentieren will, sehr empfehlenswert. Und kommt eben auch hier so mit so einem Clip daher, in dem man als Schlüsselanhänger verwenden kann. Es gibt auch ein Bändchen dazu oder was auch immer. Ich hab's ja immer im Rucksack jetzt einfach dabei, für alle Fälle. Ist klein genug. Wie meine natürlich umfangreiche Apple Adapter-Kollektion. Da gibt's bald bei Rucksack so ein extra Fach. Ja, jetzt auch mit Apple Adapter Sortierfach.
Was ja auch noch so ein Argument war, war diese ganze White-Color-Geschichte. Sozusagen Kamera, Display, alles ist sozusagen in der Lage, so einen Farbraum abzubilden, der weit über diese sRGB-Geschichte hinausgeht. Ich weiß gar nicht, wie man den nennt.
Ach, dieses White-Gamut oder wie, was, das meinste?
Ja.
Obwohl, das betrifft jetzt das Display. Du meinst jetzt die...
Das betrifft alles. Die Kamera ist in der Lage, soweit auch abzutasten und der Bildschirm ist in der Lage, das auch anzuzeigen. Also es geht darum, dass das sozusagen die komplette Chain drin ist und dass das eben auch alles entsprechend kalibriert ist ab Werk. Das war so ein bisschen so ihr Argument. Genauso wie diese sonstigen Späße, die sie da halt machen. Aber das ist halt drin. Dann kannst du ja irgendwie auch jetzt DNG machen, also diese RAW-Dateien, Digital Negatives, wie man sie auch nennt, sodass du dann eben deine Fotos auch noch direkt von der Kamera, vom iPhone nehmen kannst und dann in Lightroom halt auch die ganze Belichtung und den ganzen Kram quasi nachzuliefern, Hand machen kann. Ne, Apple Store gibt's nicht mehr. Die haben sie eingestellt. Hat sich nicht durchgesetzt gegen Lightroom und da haben sie dann auch gesagt, das deckt jetzt nicht mehr unseren Bedarf ab.
Ja, warum fangen die denn da überhaupt an? Das war doch richtig von Grund auf neu geprogrammiert, oder?
Ja, aber da gab's auch Lightroom noch nicht und da wollten sie sozusagen diese ganze Foto-Geschichte in ihrem Workflow halt auch pushen und das eben nur, also auch über diesen Bedarf hinaus. Ich meine, sie machen ja auch noch Final Cut Pro. Da sind sie ja auch noch voll drin in diesem Markt. Und sie machen auch noch Logic und da werden sie sicherlich auch bleiben in diesen Segmenten. Aber bei Foto haben sie halt nicht die Notwendigkeit.
Wobei ich jetzt sagen muss, jetzt ist eigentlich die Gelegenheit besser denn je auf diesen Markt zuzuschlagen, weil jetzt wo Adobe voll auf diese Creative Cloud Sache umgestiegen ist und man jetzt eigentlich kaum noch eine Chance hat, ein Adobe-Produkt ohne Creative Cloud-Abo zu bekommen, was auch nicht gerade günstig ist. Ich glaube, die Affinity-Leute hier mit Affinity-Foto, was ja lauter Preise abgesahnt hat und so weiter, das hat jetzt eine richtig gute Zeit und oder auch ihr Designer und sie machen ja bald ein Desktop-Publishing-Programm auch noch, das ist ihr dritter Kandidat sozusagen und das kostet 49 Euro im App-Store, das heißt, du kriegst auch die ganzen Updates erst mal die ganze Zeit.
Affinity macht ein Publishing?
Ja, also sie arbeiten gerade dran.
Gibt's aber noch nicht.
Gibt's noch nicht, leider. Weil das Ding ist jetzt, ich habe kürzlich meine Mitgliedschaft in der Creative Cloud sozusagen da beendet mal, die mir bezahlt wurde und dann wollte ich jetzt mal wieder gucken, okay mit welchem Tool bearbeite ich jetzt Fotos und habe mir die Creative Cloud Sache angeguckt, aber ich benutze es zu selten, als dass ich mir 20 Dollar im Monat oder Euro im Monat nur für Photoshop geben würde und eigentlich bräuchte ich auch InDesign und Illustrator und dann bist du halt bei 69 Euro im Monat, oder waren es 69? Auf jeden Fall, es war mehr, als ich bereit war sozusagen auszugeben und die Affinity Apps, die kosten halt jeweils 49 Euro und können im Prinzip alles, was ich von Photoshop oder Illustrator bräuchte und wenn sie ihren Publisher noch rausbringen, dann bin ich einfach da komplett bei Affinity und Apple hätte da sicherlich jetzt auch noch eine Das wäre eine ziemlich gute Chance, weil eben eine ganze Menge Leute nicht so Bock auf diese Abo-Sache haben und wenn Apple sozusagen ihr AppStore-Modell durchzieht und bei Final Cut und Logic ist es ja so, du bezahlst halt einmal dein Geld und kriegst dann die ganzen Updates erstmal eine ganze Zeit lang. Also wir haben bisher noch keinen Final Cut X20 oder so rausgebracht, was du wieder extra kaufen müsstest. Dann wäre das schon ein sehr interessanter Deal für die ganzen Leute, die eben noch nicht tausende Euro pro Projekt absahnen und das in Abos und so weiter stecken können. Leute, die halt voll natürlich im laufenden Betrieb sind, so Freelancer-Designer wie auch immer, für die ist natürlich die Creative Cloud okay. Aber für so Gelegenheitsklicker mit Anspruch ist die andere Seite dann schon besser.
Was kosten diese Designer?
Ich glaube, die kosten alle hier 49. Ich glaube, die Affinity Apps kosten alle 50 Dollar oder Euro.
Das ist immer wieder, weil ja, also ich gehe auch nicht mehr zur Adobe, das können die vergessen. Und eigentlich bräuchte ich mal wieder so ein Vector-Tool, was mich glücklich macht. Vielleicht wäre das mal was. Aber ich könnte ja auch vor allem auf so eine Publishing-Software.
Ja, also ich bin sehr, sehr gespannt. Ich hatte ja die ganzen Betas von Affinity, schon immer angeklickt und mich daran erfreut. Aber den Publisher, den würde ich sehr, sehr gerne beta testen, schauen und gucken, wie der sich klickt. Weil ich muss sagen, die Affinity-Apps, die klicken sich wirklich alle ganz schön angenehm. Wobei sie jetzt ja auch kürzlich angefangen haben, eine Windows-App zu machen. Ihr Foto gibt es jetzt auch für Windows. Aber bitte macht es nicht mit Unity-Cross-Plattformen und nicht... Also, ne? Ne, bitte nicht. Also bisher sind es, soweit ich weiß, noch Native Apps. Übrigens noch eine kleine Geräte zu dem Thema Native Apps. Slack hat eine neue Beta für Mac OS rausgebracht, die jetzt viel schneller sich klicken soll und performen soll und so weiter und so fort.
Von was?
Von ihrem...
Mac Client. Ernsthaft? Native?
Ja, hab ich auch gleich gefragt. Nein, sie haben es in einem neuen JavaScript-Framework geschrieben. Irgendwie Ecto, Evolusio, keine Ahnung was. Aber sie versprechen trotzdem...
Gibt es da eine Version von?
Ja, es ist in dem Workflowie schon eingetragen, die U11. Fertig, mundgerecht.
Darf jeder benutzen?
Ja, es ist glaube ich einfach slack.com/beta/mac oder sowas. Müsste meinen...
Die nutzen ja das Electron-Framework.
Genau, Electron.
Ah, Electron, ja da stehen sie alle drauf.
Ich habe es jetzt noch nicht getestet.
Deswegen gibt es da so lange keine Updates mehr. Verstehe. Hoffentlich haben sie da ordentlich Sharing eingebaut.
Na ja, freu dich nicht zu früh, ne? Wieso ist es noch nicht getestet? Ich habe es noch nicht getestet, aber jetzt nur von den vollmundigen Versprechungen. Vielleicht noch nicht die Excitement-Regler alle nach auf 11 drehen.
Doch, du weißt doch, jede Beta-Version hält immer, was sie verspricht.
Gerade die gewrappten Web-Apps. Ich habe mich mit einem ganz anderen Menschen darüber unterhalten, dann hat mir der Typ von Slack, der da irgendwie der Twitter-PR beauftragt ist, geschrieben, ja, weil ich gemosert hätte, ist ja wieder nur so ein JavaScript-Web-Kram, meinte er, ja, das Leben ist zu kurz, um zu gucken, wie NS-String funktioniert und so weiter. Und dann dachte ich, okay, Thema direkt irgendwie beendet. Wir reden jetzt nicht über die ganzen Millionen von Entwicklerjahren, die ihr mit eurer Slackish-App und so weiter verschwendet habt in Summe. Ja, also es wäre jetzt auch dramatisch, wenn sie versprechen würden, dass es sehr viel schneller ist und ich lad mir auch mal die Beta. Gibt's auch für Windows übrigens eine Beta, ach ne, die ist aber 2.2.0. Ich weiß nicht, ob die dann auch besser flitzt. So, Gretel wieder beendet.
Also es ist flutschig genug, als dass man das mal probieren kann. Scheint auch zu funktionieren so auf den ersten.
Übernimmt es auch die Settings von der alten.
Ja, einfach starten geht.
Sie baden gerade ihre Hände drin.
Vielleicht geht es ja sogar mit dem Recizen.
So, Jungs, weitermachen. Wie sieht es aus? Ihr seid ja jetzt böse reingegritzt. Ich weiß doch, woher ihr gekommen seid.
Irgendwie waren wir, also Klammer zu, erstmal mit dem Slack, Klammer zu, Affinity, Klammer zu, Foto, Klammer zu, Kamera. Ich hab meinen Scope und Stack irgendwie alles abgebaut wieder. Alles am Start.
Das heißt, mit der Hardware an dem Phone wären wir jetzt durch oder war da noch irgendwas? LTE-Bände haben sie nicht geändert, das ist ja auch für Leute noch wichtig.
Doch, ich glaube, da ist auch wieder was dazugekommen.
Okay, kein neues Band, aber schneller.
Ich weiß nicht, ob da nicht nur ein Band dazugekommen ist, aber wenn dann nicht alle drin, oder? Da kommen ja auch am Lauf eine Meter welche dazu, glaube ich, je Nachtland. Sie haben halt noch diesen ganzen neuen NFC-Mumpel von Japan jetzt irgendwie noch mit dabei. Ich habe ja schon leicht hyperventiliert, als sie irgendwie anfingen mit, ja, und jetzt Apple Pay in weiteren Ländern, eins davon ist Japan, nicht so weitere Länder, und was war es dann? Irgendwie Neuseeland und, weiß nicht, Lichtensteine, keine Ahnung. Auf jeden Fall sind wir immer noch nicht dabei und ich finde das ein bisschen bekloppt.
Wird schon, ganz ruhig, kommt.
Ja, aber es ist halt auch hier teilweise einfach noch nicht so ausgerollt. Also es kann halt auch sein, dass sie einfach sich den deutschen Markt anschauen und sagen, bringt erst mal genug Terminals hier auf die Straße.
Na Terminals gibt es doch.
Ja, also ich habe das so im letzten halben Jahr jetzt mal so etwas gezielter probiert, vor allem jetzt so diesen Sommer. Und einfach versucht mal gnadenlos überall mal so zu checken, ob die eigentlich Kontakt haben oder nicht. Man erkennt das ja, wenn die so auf EC-Kartenmodus schalten, man erkennt es ja eigentlich daran, dass wenn das Display sich umschaltet, mitstecken sie die Karte rein, dann hast du oben so vier Punkte, die sich so füllen, wenn du halt da eine kontaktlose Karte dranhältst. Daran kann man das halt schon mal sehen. Aber das Problem ist natürlich, wenn du dann die Leute auch fragst, haben sie kontaktlose Bezahlungen? Dann ist das wieder so eine Frage wie Vor 20 Jahren haben sie hier Internet oder was, also irgendwas. Genau, was wollen sie? Eine Steckdose im Zug? Wozu sollte man eine Steckdose im Zug gebrauchen? Leute, bitte lasst mich in Frieden.
Eine Freundin von mir hat sich letztens, ich sag mal kurz, paddeln irgendwie hier auch arbeitslos, mitten in der Woche auf dem See. Und dann hat die halt irgendwie die ganzen Leute, die da so vorbeipaddeln, die sagen ja hallo oder stellen irgendwelche dämlichen Fragen. Also nicht dämlich, aber manche so pseudo-lustig halt. Dann hat sie irgendwie angefangen, irgendwie die jüngeren Leute zu fragen, ob sie dann wüssten, was das Wi-Fi-Passwort hier wäre. Und das halt so mitten auf dem See. Und die Reaktionen waren auch ganz schön so richtig. Was? So erste Reaktionen so, Wi-Fi-Passwort, Wi-Fi-Passwort. Oh, wir sind auf dem See, das ist ein Spaß. War so ein schöner kleiner Fnord, hab ich mich sehr amüsiert.
Der richtige Fnord wäre, wenn einer geantwortet hättet, ihr sah tolle Verarschen und dann hättet's sogar funktioniert.
Anyway, also dieses iPhone-Thema, das verliert so seine Gravitation. Wir schweifen sehr viel ab.
Nee, wir sind ja auch durch. Ich meine, was soll man ja dazu noch sagen? Ich meine, wir könnten jetzt noch, wir könnten auf iOS 10 vielleicht noch mal zu sprechen kommen. Auf jeden Fall. Weil das finde ich doch, also ich hab's jetzt wie ihr wahrscheinlich auch.
Also was wir noch vergessen haben ist der Stereo-Speaker.
Den wir hiermit erwähnt haben. Ja, ich meine, wir sind ja keine Apple-Podcast.
Ja, aber iOS 10 können wir reden. Gibt's ja jetzt seit vorgestern, ne? Gestern? Gestern?
Gestern kam es raus und ich konnte mich in eingeschränktem Maße damit beschäftigen, weil ich ja nur ein iPhone 5 habe und da ist so der Spaß so ein bisschen eingeschränkt. So Sachen, auf die ich gewartet habe, wie dieses Wake on Rays.
Ja, das ging mir voll auf den Sack, hab ich gleich erstmal ausgemacht.
Echt? Warum?
Weil... Weil ich das kontraproduktiv finde, wenn ich das Gerät hoch nehme und drücke, um mich einzuloggen, aus Gewohnheit und das dann aber schon selber irgendwie angeht. Weil drücken muss ich ja trotzdem alles, also dann brauch ich das nicht.
Was ist jetzt der Unterschied, dass der Bildschirm angeht?
Ja, weil ich will sowieso drücken, das überrascht mich, weil es versucht, schneller irgendwas zu machen, als ich das will. Und das ist unnötig. Entweder ich drücke da jetzt sowieso drauf, weil ich nehme es da hoch. Also da gibt es null Vorteil, dass es irgendwie erkennt, dass ich es jetzt anmachen will, weil ich muss eh drücken. So, das heißt, ich habe eigentlich nur einen Nachteil, dass er ab und zu angeht, obwohl ich es nicht anmachen wollte. Im schlimmsten Fall. So gesehen, weiß ich nicht, was das bringen soll. Bei der Uhr ist das was anderes, weil dann kann ich mir einen Arm sparen. Man muss hochheben, man muss nicht nochmal drücken, das sehe ich ein, aber beim Telefon...
Ebenst du dein iPhone mit beiden Händen hoch?
Nein, aber im Telefon, wenn ich es hochhebe, dann... Wie gesagt, du musst trotzdem drücken, du musst trotzdem deinen Finger draufhalten und so. Deswegen sehe ich das nicht so... Ja, ich finde das kontraproduktiv. Und ich finde es auch immer noch schlecht, weil ich habe jetzt ganz oft, dass ich irgendwie drücke, dann komme ich aber nicht rein, dann sagt er mir, du musst nochmal den Homebutton pressen. Ich habe das Gefühl, ich nutze den Button jetzt da unten doppelt so viel. Also Apple will wohl, dass man ihn jetzt kaputt drückt, damit man auf ein iPhone 7 wechselt, wo das nicht mehr geht. Ich muss jetzt mal Dampf ablassen, weil es geht mir wirklich auf den Sack.
Okay. Was sind noch so Features? Ich habe nämlich weder mir durchgesucht, was iOS 10 kann, noch habe ich es bisher installiert. Also es wurde mir noch nicht aufgedrängt.
Features, weiß ich nicht, da müsste man jetzt wieder alles gucken, was es da so gibt. Also sie haben schon ganz schön viel umgestreckt. Ein Hauptding ist halt, dass jetzt die Notifications, dass alles so ein bisschen um- und aufgeräumt wurde und so weiter. Vielleicht auch zum Besseren, das kann ich noch nicht so sagen, da muss man sich eine Weile daran gewöhnen. Aber dann bei Messages gibt es halt diese, wie war das, diese Sticker oder wie die heißen? Ja, das ist alles nicht so spannend, aber eine klarer, die interessant ist.
Also auch nur eher so kosmetische Verwässerung.
Na ja, doch, wie gesagt, bei Message, also hier bei iMessage oder Message heißt das ja, da kann man jetzt auch als App-Developer Plugins schreiben, dass du halt jemand anderem per iMessage auch irgendwie was rüberschickst und wenn der das gleiche Plugin hat und das wird ihm angeboten, wenn er es nicht hat, dass ihr dann so Spezialsachen über diese Verbindung austauschen könnt. Also es gibt zum Beispiel einen Bitcoin-Starter in den USA, der heißt Circle und der hat schon gleich so ein Plugin rausgebracht, dass man da jemand anderem, der auch ein iPhone hat, dann per iMessage halt irgendwie Bitcoins, Dollars oder noch irgendwie was anderes so rüberschieben kann, wenn dann beide hier dieses Plugin da irgendwie installieren und so. Und also da muss man halt gucken, es ist auf jeden Fall so eine Schnittstelle, wo jetzt irgendwie Developer sich was Schickes einfallen lassen können, um da was Tolles zu coden. Ansonsten, was haben wir denn noch hier auf dem Startschirm? So Kalender, weiß nicht, was das da anders ist, sieht ziemlich gleich aus, können nur Kleinigkeiten sein. Fotos, Fotos ist ganz neu. Erstens entdeckt das iPhone, Quatsch, das iOS 7, Quatsch, iOS 10, so jetzt, findet, wenn dein Telefon aus ist, also nachdem du es frisch installiert hast, dann sagt es, wenn du da, da gibt es so ein Ordner, der People heißt und wenn dein Telefon aus ist, fängt er an durch deine ganzen Bilder durchzugehen und alle Leute zu suchen, also Bilder mit, mit Leuten drauf und sortiert die dann zusammen, sodass ein Ordner mit nur Huckel-Fotos, ein Ordner nur mit Timmer-Fotos und ein Ordner mit Dendes-Fotos und das ist erschreckend genau, also was der da für Bilder kennt, wo du irgendwie, keine Ahnung, voll rasiert oder nee, unrasiert bist und irgendwie...
Voll unrasiert.
Voll unrasiert, deine Hand ist vom Gesicht und auch sonst würde dich eigentlich nicht mal deine Mama erkennen und der sagt hier, ja das bist ja du. Und das ist schon so ein bisschen scary, es funktioniert ganz schön gut. Man muss, kann ihm auch noch so ein paar Sachen erkennt, dann muss er sagen, ja nee, hier das gehört noch da und dazu, aber das ist zumindest ein neues Feature, wenn man halt eine bestimmte Person sucht, hat man jetzt ein Ordner, wo die denn schneller da zu finden ist, dann...
Es ist übrigens bei mir nicht, auf dem iPhone 5 nicht verfügbar.
Da hat er zu wenig Bums wahrscheinlich.
Auweia, also ich guck grad hier auf der Apple iOS 10-Seite und das ist ja ein halber Kilometer nur mit Messages. Du kannst jetzt ein Foto verdeckt schicken und dann musst du swipen, um es zu revealen.
Ja, das ist spannender.
Na ja, das ist ROT13 im 21. Find ich eigentlich ganz geil.
ROT13?
Dann gibt's bei Fotos noch so eine Memory-Funktion. Zum Beispiel, ich war mal mit meinem Kumpel Krüxen, wir waren mal September 2010 auf Motorrad-Tour. Und irgendwie haben wir ja lauter Bilder geschossen. Ich hatte ja auch schon ein iPhone und in den Bildern steht ja drin, wo die geschossen sind. Und dann macht ihr dieses iPhone und ich hab jetzt hier nichts gemacht, das ist per Default so, ja. Machen die da so ein Standard-Movie draus und mit so ein bisschen Geklimper an Musik macht er jetzt hier Sachsen-Anhalt, sagt dann nach Baden-Württemberg und macht da so ein Mini-Movie aus unserer Motorrad-Tour, aus den Bildern, die ich da gemacht hab.
Ken Burns Effect.
Weiß genau, welche Bilder ich genau da geschossen hab, weil das halt ein so ein Roadtrip war und das hat er erkannt und hat da jetzt so ein, macht da so eine Diashow mit ein bisschen Bewegung und Musik draus. Was jetzt hier ohne Audio war. Audio macht er nämlich auch.
Okay, man kann jetzt Tische reservieren und Restaurants mit Apple Maps.
Hier, so eine Musik kommt dann nach.
Mit schöne Weltmusik.
Klar, was denn sonst? Noch merkt er sich nicht, welche Musik wir zu der Zeit gehört haben, aber es kommt bestimmt auch noch.
Ich möchte was ganz anderes betonen. Also abgesehen, dass es natürlich zahlreiche kleine Refinements gibt, die sicherlich wünschenswert sind. So was ich jetzt weiß, auch besseres Redding in Mail und so. Aber ich finde eine Sache, finde ich wirklich bemerkenswert. Da fühle ich mich auch besser. Ihr wisst auch noch, wie ich mich irgendwie völlig quer gelegt habe, als diese iOS 7-Nummer angedampft kam und dieser neue Look und Buttons und so weiter. Und manches davon habe ich ja auch dann auch internalisiert und mag auch teilweise meine Meinung geändert haben. Trotz alledem gab es so ein paar Sachen, wo ich eigentlich immer der Meinung war, ganz so scheiße war das jetzt auch nicht. So und da ist jetzt irgendwie was verloren gegangen. Und ich finde, iOS 10 bringt eine ganze Menge von den Sachen, die mir von iOS 6 gefehlt haben, wie es schon bei 8 und 9 auch immer so kleine Schritte waren. Aber was jetzt auf einmal wieder da ist, ist Farbe. Sie haben an ganz vielen Stellen ihre einfache Linien-Grafik-Icons wieder mit Signalfarben gepaart. Also sehr auffällig ist das zum Beispiel in der Maps-Anwendung, den Karten. Da ist so ein Stopp-Button, ist rot und überhaupt so alles. Hat auch sehr viel mehr so Verkehrszeichen-Optik. Die Farben sind einfach satter geworden. Es werden mehr Farben verwendet. Buttons sind auf einmal wieder buttonartiger. Und vor allem kommunizieren sie mehr. Ich habe auch das Gefühl, die Systemschrift ist ein Tick fetter geworden. Bei iOS 7 war das ja so mega dünn. Und dann ist es mit 8, 9 besser geworden. Und jetzt haben sie nochmal so einen Schritt gemacht. Also in gewisser Weise haben sie jetzt wieder sehr viele Dinge von dem, was sie so mit iOS 6, Holter-Dee-Polter verlassen haben, durch diesen radikalen Wandel, haben sie jetzt wieder zurückgebaut. Und jetzt so eine Melange und so eine Balance, wie ich finde, auch so in der ganzen visuellen Kommunikation gefunden, die mich doch sehr anspricht.
Du bist wieder zu Hause.
Ja, weil wenn sie... Ja, vor allem, also ich komme mir auch nicht mehr so bekloppt vor. Weil ich meine, wenn du irgendwie dann anfängst, so im Alter Mann-Modus, sich irgendwie aus dem Fenster zu lehnen, dann so, äh, ja, aber alles besser. Dann kommt man sich ja dann auch ein bisschen affig vor, ist ja auch affig. So, aber manchmal hat man ja schon auch so ein Gespür dafür, dass Dinge so falsch jetzt auch nicht waren und schon auch vielleicht so am Ende einer Evolutionskette standen, wo jetzt nicht alles falsch war früher. Also Krokodile mögen ja sehr altbacken aussehen, aber sie überleben ja auch schon irgendwie viele Millionen Jahre, damit sie erfolgreich und sehr viel besser kannst du sie wahrscheinlich kaum bauen.
Ich hatte gerade einen lustigen Moment hier, und zwar bin ich ja eigentlich Hasser von diesem 3D-Touch oder Force-Touch, ne? Jetzt habe ich aber gesehen, dass ich in diesen neuen Apps war, gerade so ein Blobbel so größer als der Rest, und habe gesehen, dass da so ein Marker von mir ist, der da irgendwie noch geblieben ist, und habe ich versucht, den wegzukriegen, und das ging nicht. Also da unten wurde alles angezeigt, Direction und Zeug und so im Menü zu diesem Marker, aber da war kein Remove Pin-Button, ne?
Das geht jetzt damit.
Und dann dachte ich, okay, dann drückst du mal Dollar, wie beim OS X, wenn irgendwas nicht geht, drückst du Alt, ist einfach so, und dann geht's. Und das habe ich jetzt hier Force-Touch gemacht und tatsächlich Remove Pin, und dann geht's. Das heißt, zum ersten Mal haben sie es geschafft, mich intuitiv dazu zu zwingen, Force-Touch zu benutzen. Vielleicht wird es ja doch noch was, aber sonst, ich mag es immer noch nicht. Was ich aber an einer neuen Maps-App nicht mag, ist diese Suchleiste da unten geht nicht raus. Bei der alten Map war das irgendwie so, du konntest einmal klicken und alles angehört, ist verschwunden und du hast nur noch irgendwie die Karte und sonst nix und das geht jetzt nicht mehr und das geht mir sowas von auf den Sack.
Ach, die ist immer da?
Die ist immer da und du kriegst es dann nicht weg. Und ich sagte auch, das dauert nicht bis 10.1 und die haben das weggemacht.
Ja, das glaube ich auch. Vor allem, da ist ja so ein Schieberteil auch noch dran.
Ja, den kannst du hochschieben, dann kommt noch mehr. Ist ja auch okay, aber das muss weggehen. Das geht gar nicht. Vor allem, mach mal in Landscape Mode, da ist der halbe Bildschirm mit der Search-Barder voll. Und ich meine, das geht überhaupt nicht. Ich hab nicht so viel Platz hier auf dem Phone, Jungs. Das ist klein und ich muss was sehen.
Das ist ja bekloppt.
Und wenn wir schon mal dabei sind, bei Screen Real Estate. Was noch geil ist.
Sie zeigen die Temperatur an. Das ist ja geil. Du zoomst auf irgendwas ein und dann sagen sie, wie warm es da ist.
Wie cool.
Also hab ich das gar nicht betrachtet, weil ich bisher immer nur in Berlin rumgescrollt habe. Aber stimmt, wenn man mal woanders scrollt, dann weiß man auch gleich, wie warm gerade da ist.
Ja, wenn du mal wissen willst, wie warm es am Nordpol ist.
Ja, scrollt sie einfach mal hin.
Scrollt sie mal hin. Hier so Grönland aktuell. Gibt es schon ein paar Orte in Grönland, oder?
So, was mir noch aufgefallen ist bei Messages, ja? Da hat man ja oben das normale Menü, da wo halt auch Messages steht. Oder wenn man halt mit einem User chattet, steht ja der Username da. Wenn man jetzt aber auf den User geht, dann wird diese Leiste oben, die den User anzeigt, wird jetzt größer. Guck mal, wie dick die ist. Und jetzt wird sie wieder kleiner. Und jetzt wird sie wieder dicker. Also als wenn ich da irgendwie zu viel Platz hätte auf meinem Phone.
Ja, weißt du, sie sparen die...
Sie sparen überall ein und dann verbadern sie es jetzt plötzlich woanders.
Ja, vor allen Dingen sparen die Klinkenbuchse, damit sie da mehr irgendwie Gizmo einbauen können, aber dann verschwenden sie den halben Screen mit einer Searchbar.
Vor allem unnötig. Also ich meine, es sind hier wieder, keine Ahnung, 5 Millimeter, die so das Ding größer machen, nur damit sie den Namen jetzt schick mit Icon irgendwie anzeigen können. Ja, also ich bin das gefällt mir überhaupt gar nicht.
Also das mit der Suchleiste ist ja auch wirklich hanebüchen. Aber gut, da bin ich mir auch relativ sicher, das wird da nicht langer Bestand haben.
Ja und ich hoffe, dass bei den Messages, dass die da mehr Platz verbrauchen auch nicht. Oder dass man sie da abschalten kann. Vielleicht geht das ja sogar, dass ich das abschalten kann, wer weiß. Vielleicht mit Force-Touch.
Also sie können ja auch gleich die Pokestops mit einblenden.
Ja, Map-Plugins kommt vielleicht auch noch.
Gibt's ja doch schon oder nicht? War da nicht von die Rede? War da nicht schon von iOS 9 die Rede? Ich weiß jetzt nicht mehr so ganz genau. Ich finde das auf jeden Fall sehr begrüßenswert. Farbe wird wieder benutzt, dünne Linien sind dicker. Ich gehe mit. Und da ist sicherlich noch das eine oder andere zu fixen und rumzuhackeln, aber ich finde die Tendenz gut. Und was ich heute auch schon mal ausprobiert habe, diese neue Funktionalität mit diesem VoIP API. Da gibt es ja jetzt die neue Version von WhatsApp. Nein, WhatsApp benutze ich normalerweise nicht. Außer, dass mir Leute Nachrichten schicken, ganz unaufgefordert, weil das passiert einem ja. Das sind immer diese wundersamen Telefonnummern-Mapper. Und man kann ja mit WhatsApp auch so Voice-over-IP-Calls machen, Netzcalls. Und ja, diese neue WhatsApp, das Update von dieser App benutzt halt dieses VoIP-AP. Und wenn du halt jetzt über WhatsApp angerufen wirst, klingelt das Telefon halt so, als wär's ein normaler GSM-Call.
Das ist aber erst ab iOS 10, oder wie?
Allerdings klingelt es nicht auf der Uhr. Ja, ich find das lustig, dass Sie jetzt sozusagen auf Telefon kommen mit der Experience. Ich hab ja jetzt schon wieder einen Schritt weiter, bin jetzt sicher schon auf der Uhr und erwarte, wenn mich einer anruft, dass es auf meiner Uhr klingelt. Und da klingelt es halt nicht. Also ich krieg da noch nicht mal eine Nachricht. Und das ist natürlich bekloppt, aber vielleicht können Sie das selber auch noch irgendwie nachreichen mit einer entsprechenden App, da bin ich mir nicht so ganz so sicher, was die WatcherS APs da so hergeben. Aber ich finde das generell gut. Und jetzt warte ich darauf, dass halt so Zip-Client, vor allem I'm looking at you, GroundWire, das mal ganz schnell nachrüsten. Aber ich hab so den Eindruck, da werden die sich nicht lange bitten lassen, weil das ist natürlich die bestmögliche Integration, die man sich so vorstellen kann.
Was noch neu ist bei iOS 10 ist die Musik-App. Wie heißt die eigentlich? Doch Music heißt die, die da ist. Vorher war ja alles bei iOS 9. Ich red jetzt von der eigenen Musik, die man sich so drauf spielt, wenn man jetzt kein Apple Music hat, sondern wirklich, wenn man noch seine CDs......selber gerippt... .selber gerippt hat lassen, weiß schon. Und da war vorher irgendwie so, dass du halt so ein Table View mit dein Art ist, und dann bist du reingegangen. Und dann war, wenn du im Album warst, und sagen wir mal, das Album war jetzt total blau, dann war der Hintergrund auch so bläulich angehochst. So wie das im iTunes-Manier auch gefehlt hat. So, was machen sie bei iOS 10? Komplett alles wieder weg. Ich hab mich gerade dran gewöhnt, fand es eigentlich ziemlich cool, dass du auch gleich so einen Wiedererkennungswert hattest, dass du weißt, das Album, das hat die Farbe, das hat die Farbe. Also man guckt ja nicht nur nach Text, sondern auch nach so den Farben und nach der Optik. Und jetzt ist alles wieder weg, jetzt ist alles wieder weiß. Sie zeigen zwar jetzt die Alben schön an, immer so zwei nebeneinander irgendwie. Das ist eigentlich so ganz schick, oder?
Das ist deutlich besser, ja.
Das ist deutlich besser. Aber dann finde ich auch bekloppt, ich bin zum Beispiel jetzt hier im Pink Floyd Ordner. Und was ist? Wir zeigen jetzt pro Album nochmal an, das ist, von wem kann man wohl raten? Von Pink Floyd. Das heißt, wieder geht irgendwie 10% pro Album wieder dafür drauf, damit sie mir nochmal erzählen, das ist jetzt auch wirklich von Pink Floyd.
Das wird man da nochmal sagen dürfen.
Ja, aber ich bin im Ordner Pink Floyd. Bei so Shuffle-Compilations, da können sie das ja machen, aber sie können ja wohl erkennen, alles klar ist, der Pink Floyd Ordner, das sind jetzt alles Alben von Pink Floyd, brauchen wir nicht mehr anzeigen, das sind keine Ahnung. So ein paar Zeilen Code. Kann dann nicht so schwer sein.
Muss man denn alles alleine machen?
Aber sowas könnte mich immer aufregen, das geht nicht. Da ist wirklich nicht so viel Platz auf diesem Gerät und dann verschwenden sie das mit so einem Scheiß.
Na, wenn es iTunes Matches dafür funktioniert, dann bin ich ja schon zufrieden. Wäre ich ja schon zufrieden. Und was mir ja auch aufgefallen ist, diese bekloppten iTunes Match, sie singen Musik. Sie singen nicht Hörbücher.
Da hast du das schon beim letzten Mal erzählt.
Das ist immer noch Outrageous. Ich werde das jetzt jede Sendung wiederholen.
Ja, aber nur einmal. So, was haben wir noch?
Wir sind jetzt bei Sierra noch.
Nein, beim iOS sind wir noch.
Der Chat ist schon wieder einen Schritt vorwärts. GroundWire hat CallKit Submitted. It's coming!
Warum spricht man davon? Hören sie auch schon auf mein.
Super, was für ein Turnaround war?
Die Kontexte sind ein bisschen neu gemacht. Da kann man aber nicht so cool rumspielen, weil dann ruft man mal gleich aus Versehen Leute an. Da muss man immer vorher aufpassen, was man da so drückt. Aber ganz klar ist es mir noch nicht. Dieses HomeKit-App ist jetzt mit drauf. Das war ja vorher nicht, die ist komplett neu.
Da bin ich mal gespannt, was dabei rauskommt.
Ja, ich hab leider noch so eine Geräte nicht, kann da nicht so viel dazu sagen. Die Podcast-App ist eher so deine Liga, da müsstest du gucken, da ist bei mir nichts.
Hab ich noch gar nicht drauf geschaut, was für Verbrechen sie da jetzt wieder begangen haben.
Bei mir ist doch alles leer.
Da sprechen wir nächste Folge drüber nach.
Gar nicht so viel zu erzählen. Was haben wir noch hier? Es ist ja jetzt erlaubt, dass man die Apps von Apple, dass man die löschen kann, wenn man sie nicht haben will. Aber wie ich heute gelesen hab, die werden dann nur entfernt aus dem Springboard. Sie werden nicht wirklich gelöscht. Die liegen noch weiterhin. Also du kriegst die Megabytes nicht gut geschrieben, weil die ja gesigned sind und zum Standardpaket gehört. Und deswegen können sie die nicht entfernen, weil...... Ja, das stimmt. Aber haben sie halt noch mal extra erwähnt irgendwie. So, was hätten wir denn noch hier, so Mail, ja... So ein Mail-Stread sind die jetzt hintereinander weg. Man kann einfach so durch scrollen, das war vorher nicht so. Man musste mal rein, raus aus den Mails. Das hat ein bisschen genervt. Oder oben hier diese Buttons da drücken. Das finde ich jetzt besser mit dem Scrollen.
Das ist in der Tat ein Schritt nach vorne.
Ja, so wie es vom Gefühl ist, ist der Apple Store jetzt nicht doll anders. Da ist alles gleich. Aber sie schaffen es jetzt endlich, ihre Eigens ordentlich zu laden. Das ging ja mal irgendwie. Seit iOS 9 war das ja dauerkaputt eigentlich, dass er nie die Eigens so richtig geladen hat. Wenn also irgendwie kein Netz war und er konnte das Eigens nicht laden, dann hat er das auch nachträglich nie wieder hingekriegt. Also das war irgendwie, hatten die da Probleme mit ihren App-Eigens. Das scheint jetzt zu funktionieren.
Lohnt sich auf jeden Fall, mal alle Apps mal durchzuklicken, ist immer mal wieder was Lustiges dabei. So Kleinigkeiten.
Safari habe ich jetzt bisher nichts anderes entdeckt.
Zum Beispiel bei der Uhr gibt es jetzt irgendwie die Möglichkeit, deine Schlafenszeiten einzustellen. Schlafenszeit. Schlafzeiten hätte es eigentlich heißen müssen.
Genau, das ist ein neues Feature, Bad Time. Da fragt er mich auch, wenn du regelmäßig aufstehen willst, dann gucke ich auf die Uhr, so 5 Uhr morgens, so regelmäßig kann man jetzt gut sagen, ich gehe jetzt mal schlafen. Deswegen konnte ich das noch nicht testen, weil ich glaube, das würde abstürzen, das Telefon, wenn das mein Schlafbrust ist.
Mit deinem Bio-Rhythmus.
Das geht einfach nicht.
Das ist für Leute mit Kindern.
Ja, wobei man täglich irgendwie, wenn um 8 der Bäcker klingelt, oder um 6, oder um 5. Hatte ich alles früher, muss ich nicht nochmal haben.
Das mit den Kindern kann ja schnell passieren. Hört nicht viel dazu.
Dann fällt mir jetzt erstmal hier so nicht so viel ein mehr, glaube ich. Oder? Was gibt es denn noch so? Ich glaube, das war's.
Vor allem so Änderungen halt auch so im Unterbau. Können wir auch gleich nochmal zu Sierra weiterleiten, was so Networking betrifft. Das geht ja dann wahrscheinlich für Sierra genauso. Das ist jetzt auch so das Security Cleanup Release, wo sie diese ganzen alten SSL-Versionen ja endlich dann mal komplett raushauen. Warum auch immer das so lange gedauert hat.
Also der RC4 ist rausgeschmissen worden, SSL-Version 3 haben sie rausgeschmissen. Dann, wenn man hier sich einen VPN mit TTPT, hieß das so? PPTP, genau, das ist das von Microsoft, was vor Jahren schon irgendwie gehackt wurde mit so einem Service. Gibt es einen Artikel bei Heise, wo sie den mal benutzt haben. Es hat auch funktioniert einigermaßen. Also das haben sie auch entfernt mal. Das war auch mal Zeit. Dann das eigentlich sozusagen meine Lieblingsnachricht vom neuen iOS 10. Ich hab ja jetzt schon seit, ich glaube seit iOS 8 ging das los. Da hat das iPhone ja dieses IPSEC-IQ Version 2 unterstützt. Und ich hab das ja immer schön benutzt und viel. Das Problem war aber, wenn sich irgendwie deine Absende-Adresse ändert oder besser schon dein Absende-Port, was durch einen Nut ja öfter mal sein kann, wenn so ein Timeout kommt, dann ändert sich dein Absende-UDP-Port. Und dann hat sich das irgendwie aufgehangen. Das IPSEC hat auch nicht neu gestartet, sondern blieb hängen und ich muss das halt von Hand irgendwie ausmachen, wieder anschalten, damit es wieder geht. Und jetzt endlich, seit iOS 10, funktioniert es. Das heißt, ich kann das jetzt anmachen. IPSEC, dass es dauer anbleibt und sich, wenn es irgendwie mit dem Netz nicht klappt, dass er sich dann auch reconnectet und die Verbindung neu macht. Also ich hatte das letztens drei Tage am Stück an und musste nicht immer von Hand das an- und ausmachen, sondern es hat sich einfach immer wieder dafür gesorgt, dass es läuft und dass es funktioniert. Und das geht sogar bei mir jetzt auch über IPv6. Das heißt, wenn ich nur IPv6 hätte, könnte ich dann auch meinen IPSEC da drüber fahren. Also das alles, also es ging wahrscheinlich vorher auch schon, habe ich aber noch nicht getestet gehabt, aber es geht jetzt auch irgendwie. Und da bin ich demnächst auch noch weiter am machen und am tun mit jemandem zusammen, der das auch testet. Ne?
Ja, man hat das Gefühl, dass sich da auf jeden Fall eine Menge unter der Haube tut. Es hat sich auch noch was geändert. Das geht ja dann auch für... Also ich weiß gar nicht, ob das jetzt auch für iOS 10 gilt, aber wahrscheinlich, das neue IPv6-Verhalten.
Dieses mit Adresse?
Beschreib mal kurz.
Ja, das muss man ein bisschen ausholen. Also normalerweise, wenn man IPv6 hat, dann kriegst du ja nicht eine Adresse, sondern du kriegst ein sogenanntes Slash 56 oder 64. Ich weiß nicht, der Klemenz wird jetzt wahrscheinlich schon wieder rotieren. Aber man kriegt ein so großes Netz, was deutlich größer ist als das, was die Erde gerade per IPv4 hat. Und zwar so 16 Millionen Mal größer, wenn ich das jetzt richtig durchgerechnet habe. Also deutlich größer.
Nur für einen selbst.
Nur für einen selbst. Und du hast da vielleicht auch mehrere Rechner zu Hause. Und dann wird allen gesagt, hier, das hier ist irgendwie dein Netz. Also deine Adresse. Und pack mal hier deine Mac-Adresse mit rein. Und dann ist das deine Standard IPv6-Adresse, die du so hast. Das war jetzt sehr einfach erklärt. Und da war so viel Platz hinten im Netzwerkbereich, dass man die Mac-Adresse da rein kleben konnte. Das war aber natürlich, privacy-mäßig gesehen, war das halt keine so gute Sache. Weil, wenn du halt hier bist, ist deine Mac-Adresse in deiner IPv6-Adresse drin. Und wenn du im Café bist auch. Das heißt, man könnte dich deine Nummer mappen, weil du mit deiner Mac-Adresse mehr oder weniger auf dieser Welt rumbrennst. Und dann würde man dich direkt mappen können, obwohl das eigentlich ja nicht gehen sollte. Zumindest nicht über diese Adresse. Und dann haben sie vor Jahren sich mal was einfallen lassen und haben diese Privacy-Extension gemacht. Das ist irgendein älteres RFC auch, wo sie eine zweite Adresse einführen, die immer dann benutzt wird, wenn du eine ausgehende Connection machst, dann wird diese temporäre Adresse benutzt.
Also nicht nur eine zweite, sondern im Prinzip beliebe ich viele. Das heißt, jede neue Verbindung kriegt eigentlich eine neue Adresse, die dann für eine Weile gilt.
Wenn du zum Beispiel auf dem Ethernet hast, die gilt so lange, bis du deinen Stecker rausziehst. Wenn du ihn wieder reinsteckst, dann kriegst du schon eine neue. Jedes Mal, wenn sich diese Adresse in das Interface einträgt, dann ist es eine neue.
Ich dachte, das wäre sogar pro Prozess.
Das habe ich noch nicht gesehen.
Zumindest in den Netzwerkeinstellungen siehst du so drei oder vier verschiedene. Es gibt nicht so viele IPv6-Hosts da draußen.
Ich sehe immer nur diese eine temporäre und die ändert sich nur, wenn ich das Netzwerk hoch und runter nehme.
Ich habe bisher nie mehr als einstellig gesehen, aber es kann sich auch mittlerweile geändert haben.
Ich sehe immer nur eine einzige.
Du hast recht. Ich habe schon mal mehr als eine gesehen.
Ist egal. Das ist jetzt die eine Haupt- und die andere. Aber ich hatte hier in der Liste auch schon ein paar mehr mal stehen.
Und das sie da mit diesem FFFE in der Mitte hinten, das ist genau die mit deiner Mac-Adresse drin. Jedenfalls, weil diese temporäre, das war schon alles ganz gut, aber immer noch nicht so das wahre, weil die Adresse mit dem Mac-Adressenanteil innen drin hat man ja immer noch. Und dann gibt es jetzt ein relativ neues RFC. Was habe ich gesagt, welche Nummer das vorhin hatte? Jetzt habe ich es natürlich vergessen. Irgendwas 7217 oder 7317. Das ist von 2014, 7217. Und da wird beschrieben, dass wenn man eine IPv6-Adresse verteilt, dass man nicht die Mac-Adresse da hinten reinklebt, sondern dass sie irgendwie den Interface-Namen nehmen und dass sie den Rest von deiner IPv6-Adresse nehmen. Also aus diesem Netzbereich vorne, wo du halt eine IPv6-Adresse bekommen hast, dass sie das alles zusammenwürfeln, durchhashen und das dann halt reinpacken ansteller von deiner Mac-Adresse. Das heißt, wenn du in ein Café gehst, hast du ja vorne sogar, dein Präfix da ist ja ein anderer, weil die dann andere IPv6-Adresse verteilen. Also ist das schon mal anders. Und selbst wenn du vom Ethernet zum WLAN wechselst zu Hause, hast du auch schon eine andere Adresse, weil es ja ein anderes Interface ist. Okay, das hätte auch eine andere Mac-Adresse, so ist ja nicht. Aber sie mixen da lauter Sachen rein. Das heißt, man kann das auch nicht zurückrechnen, soll man auch nicht können, sagt auch das RFC so. Das heißt, egal wo du bist, hast du jetzt eine komplett andere Adresse, aber sie bleibt schon immer gleich.
Gut, aber die Outbound-Privacy-Extension-basierte temporäre Adresse gibt es auch noch.
Die haben sie einfach beibehalten, ja.
Genau, nur die Inbound-Adresse ist jetzt quasi auch random.
Genau.
Was natürlich jetzt...
Na ja, random schon, aber fix. Also sie ändert sich nicht mehr.
Sie ändert sich nicht mehr, bis man...
Also auf dem Interface, in dem Netz, wo du bist, da bleibt sie so. Das heißt, die würde sich jetzt nur ändern, wenn du jetzt hier eine andere IPv6 irgendwie... Genau.
Wenn ich ein anderes Netzwerk reingereicht bekomme. Okay, das kann aber schon sein.
Ja, aber dann hast du ja eh eine andere Adresse, weil dann ändert sich deine Adresse ja sowieso.
Ja, das Problem ist unter anderem, also wenn ich jetzt, wie ich das hier auch habe, ich habe hier hinten eine Fritzbox. Und ich möchte jetzt gerne von außen über V6 an meinen Rechner rankommen. Dann läuft das derzeit so, dass ich so eine Whitelist konfiguriere in der Fritzbox, indem ich nur den Hostpart angebe. Also mit anderen Worten, bisher habe ich quasi meine Mac-Adresse, den hinteren Teil, oder die Mac-Adresse quasi als hinteren Teil einer V6-Adresse in die Fritzbox rein konfiguriert und habe gesagt, egal welches Netz du kriegst, mit diesem Hostteil bitte nach hinten durchschalten. Jetzt könnte ich zwar diese Adresse, die sich nicht ändert, solange sich das Netz nicht ändert, da eintragen, aber wenn sich das Netz ändert, dann kann ich es halt...
Dann müsstest du wieder neu eintragen.
Dann kann ich es halt nicht erreichen und kann damit keinen Durchruten vom Router zu meinem Rechner. Da bin ich schon wieder in so einer komischen Falle.
Die Fritzbox müssen einfach ihre Intelligenz, die sie da irgendwie ein bisschen smarter werden.
Ja gut, aber woher sollen sie denn das wissen? Also woher sollen sie denn wissen, welche Adresse sich dieser Rechner jetzt gegeben hat? Also woran sollen sie ihn wiedererkennen, wenn nicht an dieser Mac-Adresse?
Na, der Fritzbox kann ihn ja an der Mac-Adresse wiedererkennen, weil das ja im Lokalen sind ja im gleichen Netz. Der sieht das ja schon.
Ja, aber woher soll er ihn wiedererkennen? Also Fritzbox, jetzt läuft sie. Der Rechner hat jetzt seine Adresse. Dann kommt die Telekom und sagt hier, Verbindungstrennung, weil wir wollen es euch nicht so einfach machen. Und dann taunt... Also, wo kommen wir denn dahin, wenn die Leute das Internet einfach benutzen, wenn sie das für bezahlt haben? Und dann, hier ein neues Netzwerk. Welche Möglichkeit hat eine Fritzbox, dann wird mein Rechner sich auf Basis dieser neuen Netzwerkadresse eine komplett neue IP-Adresse wiederzuerkennen, dass es derjenige ist, zu dem ich nach wie vor, wenn ich von außen connecte, hinkommen können möchte. Also, wie kann ich dieses Whitelisting sozusagen... Also, da kann ich ja nur sagen, alles ist frei. Schwierig, ne?
Ja, genau, weiß ich jetzt nicht, aber eigentlich... Hätte ich jetzt gesagt, per DHCP weiß deine Fritzbox ja auch, welche Mac-Adresse gerade da nach einer neuen Adresse gefragt hat. Okay, das ist jetzt kein DHCP mehr. Aber die machen ja immer noch Rute Advertisement, Demon und wie das alles da so heißt und so. So ein bisschen können die sich ja schon unterhalten. Ich weiß nicht, was die Fritzbox da alles so rausfinden kann.
Ja gut, aber der ganze Sinn dieser ganzen Aktion ist ja nicht identifizierbar zu werden.
Deine Fritzbox sitzt aber im gleichen Netzwerk wie du. Die kann das schon.
Ja, aber woran?
Das müssen die halt ausbaldobern.
Woran kannst du erkennen, dass es... Das ist eine andere Adresse, weil jetzt eine neue Raute bekanntgegeben worden ist. Woran kannst du erkennen, welcher dieser Rechner, der sich da gerade eine neue Adresse gegeben hat, welcher das vorher war?
Der kann es ja nicht. Das ist eine Mac-Adresse, weil die sitzt im gleichen Netzwerk.
Ja, aber die Mac-Adresse wird ja nicht mehr verwendet für die Adresse.
Aber alle Pakete von deinem Rechner sind ja auf der anderen Ebene ganz unten drunter.
Ja, Entschuldigung, ich hab vergessen, kurz mein Hirn zuzuschalten. Das wirkt sich immer negativ aus.
Jetzt muss ich ein Bild von dir mit dem Kirchner anbosen.
Ich könnte, genau, man müsste im Prinzip einfach sagen, welche Adresse auch immer, über diese Mecke drin, aber das sind natürlich auch die ganzen temporären, die da angeschossen kommen. Da kommen ja dann sozusagen verschiedene.
Ja, ich weiß nicht, ob er die jetzt noch unterscheiden kann, wie das da so gemacht ist. Da müsste man das RFC jetzt ein bisschen genauer lesen. Vielleicht nicht, das ist mir nicht so klar.
Wie denn?
Wir fragen Clemens beim nächsten Mal nochmal ausführlich, würde ich vorschlagen.
Ja, Clemens hat das Thema auf Twitter selber aufgebracht und ob AVM das schon auf dem Zeiger hätte und was denn da jetzt sozusagen die Lösung sein könnte.
Ich habe gegoogelt, ich habe noch keinen anderen gesehen, der das gefunden hat.
Ja, ich bin ehrlich gesagt schon ein bisschen vor dir draufgekommen, weil ich habe so ein kleines Skript da hier gemacht, damit irgendwie meine sich theoretisch wechselnde Adresse, die wechselt sich tatsächlich gar nicht so oft, bei so einem dynamischen, dünnen DNS-Gram von Clemens irgendwie registriert wird.
Ja, und das ging plötzlich nicht mehr.
Und auf einmal ging mein Skript nicht mehr, weil auf einmal halt was anderes im IF-Config drin stand. Vorher war da halt nur Autoconf und von dir steht da Autoconf Secure, also jetzt nicht das Problem, den Skript zu ändern, aber dadurch ist mir aufgefallen, dass mir das jetzt herkommt.
Wann denn?
Wann denn was? Na, seitdem Sarah da drauf ist.
Du hast ja auch schon Betas benutzt oder was?
Ja, auf dem iMac hab ich halt mal so umzugucken.
Nee, ich hab schon Betas, hab ich auch schon länger.
Ist denn die letzte Beta auch die GM oder nicht? Oder haben nur die Developer die GM?
Die letzte GM ist die GM.
Nein, ich meine, ist die Version, die als Public Beta rausgegeben wurde, identisch mit der jetzt für Developer definierten GM? Das weiß ich nicht.
Ich weiß nur, dass letzte Woche da stand, jetzt gibt's den GM und hab ich runtergeladen und installiert. Du kannst das ja aber an deinem Bildnummer testen. Das ist die 16A319. Gehst du mal About SysMac? Kann ich so gut Lisbillen. Vollen Niffbillen.
Lisbillen kannst du ziemlich gut.
Sag mal, 16A was?
16A319.
Ah nee, ich hab 313A.
Ja, aber dann hast du nicht mehr, sonst wär ich ja enttäuscht schon wieder hier. Ja, dann hast du noch die letzte Beta, musst einmal drüber installieren.
Nicht zu einfach machen.
Ja, nee, nicht zu einfach machen.
Ach so, iOS 10 habt ihr beide noch nicht installiert, oder doch?
Ich nicht.
Und Timme?
Bitte was?
iOS 10? Hast du schon gemerkt, dass das 10.01 ist? Wahrscheinlich haben sie noch einen Back gefunden. Das heißt, alle iPhones, die demnächst aus China da rübergeschöpft werden, haben wahrscheinlich alle noch 10.0.
Jetzt kriegst du gleich was übergebraten.
Wir sind schon eine Runde weiter.
Eine Runde weiter. Wollen wir jetzt auch mal hier so thematisch noch mal eine kleine Runde in den nächsten Gang schalten?
Bitte sehr.
Überholspur. Und hast du dein Soundboard ready?
Soundboard ready? Oh, ich ahne es schon.
Jetzt kannst du glänzen.
Unsere beliebte Sparte. Jetzt sind wir alle in derselben Hood.
The League of Excellent Mac Pro Gentleman. Ich habe es getan.
Du hast ja einen alten Computer gekauft.
Ich bin voll in das Retro-Vintage-Computing. Das ist einfach geil. Nachdem 2012er Macbook Pro, was ich hier immer noch abfeiere, bin ich jetzt in die nächste Ebene vorgedrungen des Vintage Computings und bin auf 2009 gegangen.
Das muss man sich mal reinzunehmen. Sieben Jahre alten Rechner.
Und man freut sich drüber.
Der freut sich nicht, du musst jetzt hören.
Pass mal auf. Was habe ich getan? Ihr wisst es, ich habe mir den schönsten und besten Computer gekauft, den Apple jemals gebaut hat.
Jemals.
Jemals, könnte man fast schon sagen. Der Mac Pro 4.1 in dieser Version, die ich jetzt gekauft habe.
Also eigentlich der 2008er oder?
2009.
2008 will man nicht, kauft den bloß nicht.
2009 ist 4.1, was ist denn?
2009 ist 4.1 und wir haben alle geflasht. 5.1 von 2.10.
Genau.
2008 ist der 3.1, den will man nicht, mit FB-Dim und so, das geht gar nicht. Wir können da bloß nicht anfassen.
Wir haben ja mal von einer Weile darüber gesprochen und ich hatte ja auch mal gesagt, so würde mir schon ganz gut gefallen und dann hat mir ein lieber Hörer den Tipp gegeben, dass es da so einen Store gebe, secondmac.de, also 2ND-mac war glaube ich die Adresse. Ich gucke gerade mal, oder ne, einfach nur zusammen, secondmac zusammen, aber die, genau. Und sozusagen als Tipp, wo man gepflegte, gebrauchte Apple-Rechner erwerben könnte. Und da ich jetzt gerade viel im Homeoffice bin, später mehr dazu, und sowieso sozusagen die ganze Zeit irgendwie Kabel zuhause anschließen, mein Audiointerface, Maus, Tastatur, andere USB-Geräte, hat mich das total genervt und hat mich daran wieder erinnert und dachte mir, ich gucke mal, was so ein Mac Pro kostet. Hab mit Dennis kurz gechattet, nach welchem Modell ich ausschalten muss. Es gibt glaube ich gerade bei denen keinen 4-1er, weil ich den letzten, den sie gerade da hatten, weggekauft hatte. 5-1er, aber ich habe meinen 4-1er für 629 Euro da geschossen. Hab mich vorher bei Dennis informiert, was kostet die CPU, hab geguckt, was kostet der RAM, was kostet die Grafikkarte und bin jetzt sozusagen bei knapp 1000 Euro rausgekommen und hab mir, wie Dennis, diesen Hexacore 3860. 3680. 3680 Xeon Hexacore mit 3,3 Gigahertz dazu geschoppt und hab mir auch die latest and greatest Grafikkarte nach Dennis Empfehlung, also die AMD 280X.
Das ist die, die ich hab.
Wenn du die hast, machen wir wieder gebaut. Du hast die aber dann fertig geschoppt, ne?
Genau und ich hab sozusagen dieses Firmware-Update gemacht.
Genau, das muss man ja machen, sonst geht die CPU da nicht rein.
Genau, ja, du hast auch die Karte. Dann hab ich mir diese CPU-Halt gekauft und da gab's in Berlin auch einen Laden MacFactory in so einem Kreuzberger Hinterhof Subterrain.
In der Nauhnienstraße.
In der Nauhnienstraße, genau. Ich glaub mit Bindestrich, aber guck mal, MacFactory Berlin.
Der ist noch ganz stark bei Ebay vertreten, bei Höckerter Rechner und CPUs und so. Und auch Ersatzteile übrigens.
Und Grafikkarten und alles. Und ich hab den halt, weil die eine Webseite hatten, hab ich die einfach direkt angeschrieben, weil ich wollte halt schnell die CPU. Der Rechner kam innerhalb eines Tages von Second Mac, also es war wirklich 24 Stunden UPS. Bam, hier ist dein Mac Pro. Das ging ratzfatz. Und dann wollte ich natürlich sofort die CPU haben, hab dann im Impressum geguckt, alles klar, ihr seid in Berlin, angerufen, kann ich vorbeikommen, die CPU holen? Und der Typ meinte auch so, ja, ich sag der Mitarbeiterin Bescheid, die macht eine Rechnung. Dann war ich da so in diesem Laden drin, also, naja, Laden halt nicht. So ein Zutara, so ein Halbkeller. Und ey, bis unter die Decke voll mit Mac Pro Gehäusen, ne? Und da war gerade halt so ein Mädel am CPUs stecken und Grafikkartenkartons haben sich da gestapelt von genau dieser Grafikkarte, die ja auch da ein bisschen teurer verkauft, als man sie auf Ebay schießen kann. Und hat mir halt so schön in der Antistatikfolie, also die CPU, überreicht.
Das heißt, die war aber auch, also war keine gebrauchte schon?
Hat aber 100... Ich weiß gar nicht, ich glaub 160, 190 oder 190. So neben Dreh hab ich für die CPU bezahlt. Dann schnell noch beim Konrad vorbei Wärmeleitpaste gekauft. Und dann hatte ich eigentlich schon das erste Mal so richtig, die Sonne geht auf, die Vögel singen, ich streichel den Computer und knie vor ihnen in anbetener Andacht sozusagen, weil ich dachte mir so aus alten PC-Zeiten, ich hatte den vorher noch nicht aufgemacht, ja, CPU wechseln, diesen Lüfter abpopeln, die Kabel und dieses ganze ätzende Thema. Das letzte Mal hab ich das halt nur bei PCs gemacht. Ich öffne diesen Mac Pro mit dieser Lasche, die da so hinten ist. Die Seitenwand fährt beiseite und man merkt erstmal, oh Moment mal, überhaupt gar keine Kabel in dieser Kiste. Also wirklich keine Kabel, keine sichtbaren Kabel. Und es gibt im Internet Leute, die Hackintoshes bauen und alte Cases von dem Mac Pro nehmen. Und da dann halt mit PC Hardware alles voll lümmeln und dann sieht es aber auch aus wie PC, ne? Also es war schon echt krass, einfach zu sehen, es geht auch ohne Kabel. Und dann dachte ich mir so, ok, CPU, wie kriege ich diese CPU da raus? Weil das sieht halt erstmal so ein bisschen hoch integriert aus, bis ich dann kurz auf ifixit.com geklickt habe, um mal zu sehen, wie wechsle ich die CPU und dachte mir schon, zu kompliziert gedacht.
Lösen sie die Klammer und ziehen sie die CPU raus.
Dieses Tray da raus mit diesen zwei Nupsis, die man einfach nur reindrückt und dann diesen Schlitten rausfährt mit, das war so schön. CPU-Wechsel war noch nie so eine Freude.
Das ist so wie bei so alten Minicomputern, so großen Racks, einfach alles nur auf Slide-in, Slide-out. Das gibt es einfach hier so für den Schreibtisch. Das ist wirklich Porn.
Ja und vor allen Dingen auch so keine scharfen Kanten. Alles passt. Dann hatte ich zufällig auch glücklicherweise die richtigen Imbus-Schlüssel da, weil Dennis meinte schon, man braucht so einen relativ langen, um da diese Heat-Sync abzubekommen. Aber ich habe das Proxxon Imbus-Schlüssel-Set, was lang genug war. Also die CPU-Wechsel, der war so schön und so easy.
Und vier Schrauben und fertig, oder?
Ja, und vor allen Dingen auch wie die CPU da alles so eingesetzt war. Toll, toll, toll.
Kannst du mir noch mal sagen, welchen Professor du da reingeschoben hast?
Xeon W3680.
So Timme, das Ding ist jetzt bei dir, geht ja nicht, weil diese W-Version, das ist die Billish-Version, weil davon kann man immer nur einen verbauen. Das heißt, der ist nicht Multicore-fähig, also richtig physikalische Cores. Und du hast ja so ein Dual-System da bei dir, mit zwei physikalischen CPUs und deswegen musst du von einer X-Reihe kaufen. Das ist der X-5680 und die kosten gleich mal ganz andere Summen.
Also was hast du denn bezahlt?
Ich hab viel weniger bezahlt. Auf Ebay hatte ich die nämlich günstiger verkauft, dann hab ich so angerufen, ja, also ich würde dann, wenn ich den abhole, schon lieber eher den Ebay-Preis bezahlen und dann meint der, oh ja, Webseite lange nicht geupdatet, ich mach eher halt auf Ebay eigentlich die Deals und hab mir dann nochmal 5 Euro extra weggelassen, weil Versandkosten halt wegfallen. Also ich hab glaub ich 160 oder 80 oder irgendwie sowas in dem Drehbezahl, ich weiß nicht mehr genau. Guckt auf Ebay.
Welchen kann ich nehmen?
Na der geilste ist der 5690, da der hat nochmal 133 Megahertz mehr. Der ist aber auch unverhältnismäßig teuer. Du müsstest eigentlich diesen X5680 nehmen. So, aber jetzt kommt das Ding, Timme. Wenn man sich einen so Single-CPU-Rechner kauft, so wie der Hokel gerade, dann nimmt man einen 4,1. Weil dann kann man CPUs reinstecken, die diesen Head-Spreader da oben drauf haben. Das ist dieser Metalldeckel sozusagen. Wenn man aber einen 2-CPU-Rechner hat, so wie du nämlich, 4,1, dann ist das so, dass deine CPUs diesen Head-Spreader nicht haben. Das heißt, wenn du CPUs kaufst, dann müssten das welche sein ohne Head-Spreader. Das gibt es aber kaum. Man kann sich das wegmachen lassen. Das ist aber ein Service, der wieder Geld kostet. Man kann das auch so einbauen, dass der Kühlkörper da drauf passt. Aber der ist dann ein Stück höher, weil du hast ja diesen Head-Spreader dazwischen. Und dann passt das alles nicht so richtig. Und die Anschlüsse, da musst du basteln. Wenn du das zu doll machst, dann geht die CPU kaputt. Das ist alles scheiße. Das heißt, für alle, die noch keinen Rechner haben, keinen Mac Pro, und sich gerne einholen würden, und zwei CPUs haben wollen, kauft den 5-1er. Weil da haben sie das auch alles so gebaut. Da sind auch die CPUs mit diesem Heatspreader. Und dann kann man auch prima updaten und das so wechseln, wie Huckel das gemacht hat. Und auch, wenn es zwei sind. Aber wenn man 4-1er hat und man hat zwei, dann hat man so ein bisschen die Arschkarte, dass das funktioniert. Das ist aber nicht so easy. Man muss da vorsichtig sein und das muss alles passen. Und dann gibt es im Internet auch die, jeder hat so seine anderen Tricks, und in welcher Reihenfolge man die Schrauben festzieht und bloß gleichmäßig verkantet und so. Und dann muss man 2mm Abstandshülsen haben und dann klappt alles prima. Also das ist... Das geht, aber für dein Produktionssystem hier willst du das nicht. Also deswegen Jungs, wenn ihr zwei CPUs wollt, dann müsst ihr den sauren Apfel beißen und dann müsst ihr einen 5-1er Mac kaufen. Und der Trick ist einfach, man kauft den billigsten mit den lahmsten CPUs, 5-1er und holt sich dann diese beiden fetten CPUs und knallt dir da rein.
Der Huckel hatte jetzt sogar Glück, weil der hatte gar nicht so die lahme CPU drinne, weil er hatte, du hattest eine 3540 drin, mit 2,9 GHz, weil meine war nur eine 3520 drin. Ich krieg für meine CPU bei eBay gar nichts und Huckel kriegt wenigstens noch 20 Euro. Ja, aber eigentlich brauchen wir die nicht.
Die 20 Euro, dafür mach ich mir jetzt nicht den Buckel auf eBay krumm. Dann war eigentlich nur noch das Thema Grafik hart, weil die war jetzt nicht so schnell zu bekommen. Die hab ich mir auf eBay für 120 Euro geschossen.
Aber auch gebraucht?
Aber auch gebraucht.
Die gibt's ja auch schon seit 3 Jahren nicht mehr, oder 2, eigentlich schon ein bisschen älter.
Und dann als die jetzt, also Dennis hat mir noch eine zwischendurch geliehen, aber als die dann jetzt drin war und 16 GB RAM, ach, das ist jetzt, und ich hab ja jetzt so ein 27 Zoll Dell-Display an so einem schönen Schwenkarm sozusagen. Das ist jetzt so eine Produktionssituation, das macht mich einfach jedes Mal froh, wenn ich...
Nur 16 GB RAM?
Ja, Dennis hat mir den geschenkt. Ich wollte schon auf Alternate auf 32 klicken, aber ein geschenkten Barsch schaut noch nicht hinter die Kiemen.
Kannst du gerne holen, dann gibst du mir den Speicher.
Ja klar, mach ich ja früher oder später. Aber für das erste, also ich hab den RAM bisher noch nicht so...
Hat der Bluetooth und WLAN?
Nee, noch nicht. Aber du ja auch nicht, oder?
Ich hab mich noch nicht drum geklärt.
Ja, ich hab auch schon...
Ich hab dir den Link gezeigt, ich hab ja das Modul drin. Das Blöde ist, man kann sich das einbauen, aber Apple ist halt so gemein. Und obwohl du jetzt dann Bluetooth 4.0 und auch WLAN, tralala, hast, du hast trotzdem die Features nicht, dass du dann mit deinem iPhone irgendwie hier Handover und wie die Features und Continuous da Dingens... Das benutzen die einfach nicht, weil der Mac Pro das normalerweise nicht kann und dann schalten sie es da nicht frei. Ein Jahr lang ging das und dann haben sie es irgendwie ausgemacht. Es war ziemlich ein Arschmove, aber haben sie halt so gemacht. Das heißt, so wenn du Bluetooth für was anderes brauchst und so, dann kann man das machen und sein WLAN kann man vielleicht auch ein bisschen pimpen, weil das WLAN funktioniert schon, so ist es nicht. Aber für diese mit dem iPhone quatschen Features, das geht nicht so richtig. Auch hier AirDrop und so.
Ja, das ist mir tatsächlich nicht so wichtig. Also USB 3 hätte ich gerne eigentlich noch.
Das ist aber so eine Extra-Karte.
Genau, das finde ich noch ganz super. Aber ich habe mir jetzt ein Cat 7-Kabel von meiner AirPod Extreme, meiner uralten hingelegt.
Du brauchst ja keinen WLAN mehr gerade. Weil du ja noch gar keins hast, verstehe ich. Ein Kabel ist sowieso geiler. Steht eben an der gleichen Stelle die Kiste. Dann kann man schon mal ein Kabel legen.
Kurze Klammer auf. Letztens habe ich so einen Download gemacht von einer etwas größeren Datei und habe 25 Megabyte die Sekunde bei Kabel Deutschland bekommen. Obwohl ich eigentlich ursprünglich mal ein 100 MBit Paket geklickt habe und dachte mir so...
So richtig dauerhaft 25 MBit oder er hat sich verrechnet?
Nee, das war eine größere Datei. Das hat zwar nicht so lange gedauert, wegen der 25 Megabyte die Sekunde, aber das war so richtig so... Hä, aber ich hab da nur 100 MBit eigentlich.
Du hast da wohl mehr und sie haben da...
Klammer zu. Nee, aber das ist wirklich, ich muss sagen, dieser Rechner im Vergleich zu dieser Papiertonne, die ich ja im Büro auch mehrfach habe rumstehen sehen und diesen Kabel...
Meinst du den schwarzen Mac Pro von 2013?
Den sie auch, genau. Also schon ewig nicht geupdatet haben auch.
Auch seit 2013 kam ja nie eine neue Version.
Also ich muss sagen, das ist wirklich das schönste und tollste Apple-Gerät, wenn nicht sogar PC, Desktop-Gerät, was ich jemals bisher besessen hab.
Also ich sehe das aus, ich war sofort begeistert und...
Vor allen Dingen dann noch halt, ich hatte noch eine SSD rumliegen, halt so eine Samsung Evo, aber ich meine das Ding bootet und klickt und schnackt und...
Was halt ein bisschen schade ist, ist, dass die SATA-Anschlüsse in dem Mac Pro, dass das alles nur SATA 2 ist und SATA 3, das heißt deine SSD macht so bis 280 MB die Sekunde und dann leider nicht mehr, aber dafür kann man sich ja diese PCI-Karten holen, wo man halt so diese anderen Module, diese M.2-Module, wie heißen da draufsteckt, und dann hast du da irgendwie so 600 MB, oder wenn du richtig da dicke Hose machen willst, dann gibt es die auch mit anderthalb Gigabyte die Sekunde. Dann machen die da so NVMe drüber oder irgendwie so, da gibt es auf jeden Fall was, da muss man mal im Mac room...
SSD-Module.
Da hast du eine PCI-Karte und da hat halt...
Welche Karte würdest du empfehlen?
Na, es gibt von Samsung glaube ich diese, nee, diese 950 Pro. Also 850 sind diese Standard 2,5 Zoll SSD Größen und 950 Pro ist dann dieses M.2-Format da irgendwie. Und die muss man glaube ich... Nee, die PCI-Karte ist nur so ein physikalischer Adapter, das ist nichts...
Ja, aber welche nimmt man denn da?
Das würde ich jetzt erstmal länger googeln, weil ich hab so ein Ding selber auch nicht, deswegen muss man mal gucken. Das, was ich drin hab, schafft leider nur 600, weil ich hab eine Original-Apple-SSD aus irgendeinem Laptop drin. Und dafür hatte die aber Trim, aber das hat der Apple gelöst, das Trim geht jetzt überall, deswegen kann man auch...
Außer bei den Evo's.
Weil die kaputt waren, ne?
Ja, die hatten...
Wie viel kann man denn da drauf machen, auf so eine PCI-Karte, wie viele Slots?
Ich glaub, es gibt auch Karten, wo zwei so ne Dinger drauf passen.
Aber mehr nicht.
Naja, vier.
Ja, aber nicht frei. Ich guck nur gerade, aber das Maximale, was hier CRISPR 950 Pro ist, 512 Gigabyte.
Im Chat wird gerade noch gefragt, warum. Warum Mac Pro? Und ich kann es euch sagen, also ich wollte halt einen stationären Rechner, weil Laptop habe ich auch im Büro eigentlich immer nur so, also für unterwegs ja, Laptop super. Da will man natürlich keinen Display und externe Tastatur mitschleppen. Aber wenn ich am Schreibtisch sitze, habe ich ein Display, habe ich eine Tastatur, habe ich eine Maus und fass das Laptop eigentlich nicht an und benutze es allenfalls als zweites Display. Und ich habe überlegt, welchen stationären Mac will ich zuhause haben. Und ich habe überlegt, will ich einen iMac und der ist mir wegen der Grafik-Performance zu dünn. Und ansonsten wäre der okay eigentlich, aber auch wiederum die älteren finde ich ein bisschen...
Grafik-Performance bei einem iMac, bei einem neuen iMac?
Naja, ich hätte mir so oder so, also ich hätte jetzt nicht gerne mehrere tausend Euro ausgegeben. Also es ging darum, gebrauchten Mac, Desktop-Computer, Performance, und also CPU, Grafik, RAM üppig, weil Audio gelegentlich mal irgendwas mit Video und gelegentlich mal Spiele. Und Mac Mini fällt halt auch aus, weil von allem im Prinzip zu wenig außer vielleicht CPU, aber Grafik-Performance null, Erweiterbarkeit eher nicht so und so weiter. iMac, wie gesagt, gerade auch die älteren, sind mir auch zu klobig und zu unperformant und die kann man halt auch schlecht...
Klobig? Na gut, dann Mac Pro zu gehen ist natürlich...
Na ja, nee, aber so Schreibtisch-Estate, weil ich hab jetzt so ein schwebendes, super dünnes, flaches 27 Zoll-Display, da müssen die alten iMacs schon mal erst mal mithalten.
Ja gut, aber ob das so dünn ist, ich weiß sicher eh nicht.
Ja, egal, aber ist trotzdem auf meinem Schreibtisch ein anderes Bild, sag ich mal.
Du kannst mehr Platten reinstecken, du kannst halt eine Grafikkarte irgendwie updaten und machen und so.
Genau, und dann hab ich überlegt, ok, was gibt's noch? Einen neuen Mac Pro, nur mal auf der Webseite aus Spaß geguckt oder auch auf secondmac.de und das ist halt auch so eine Preiskategorie gewesen, wollte ich jetzt nicht. Und dann hab ich auf secondmac.de geklickt und dachte mir, ok, 629 und ich komm sozusagen, ich bekomm einen fetten Computer mit allen möglichen IOPorts noch hinten dran, Grafikkarte tauschbar, RAM ohne Ende, für unter 1000. Genau, diese vier Platten-Slots, halleluja! Wirklich, das ist einfach nur großartig und das ist alles in diesem wunderschönen designten Gehäuse, was da leise und friedlich unter dem Schreibtisch summt. Also für mich wirklich so als Workstation und gerade wenn du halt viel Audio oder auch mal Video und so weiter machst, diese Platten hatte ich noch gar nicht erwähnt, aber da hatte ich auch vorher gar nicht drüber nachgedacht. Die Kiste kam mit zwei HDs und ich hab eine SSD reingesteckt. Das heißt, ich hab jetzt einfach auch ganz easy drei Platten drin und die liegen nicht auf meinem Schreibtisch rum und ich muss nicht Kabel und Adapter oder was auch immer halt, ne?
Netzteile, andere Gehäuse, noch mal Gebimsel, Kabelscheiße. Das nervt mich auch so dermaßen. Das ist irgendwie so, dieser Rechner definiert einfach alles, was zu ihm gehört, selbst.
Ich würde mir jetzt nur noch so einen Plastikrahmen für die SSD kaufen, damit die halt auch auf so einen Schlitten passt, weil im Moment hängt die halt so in der Luft.
Ich hab wirklich eine ganz interessante Debatte, weil das Ding ist natürlich nicht unbedingt so der Stromsparer, muss man natürlich auch sehen. Von daher, da sind so die neuen Geräte sicherlich in einer ganz anderen Kategorie und das ist etwas, was man beim Preis irgendwie auch mitrechnen muss. Gerade bei so Maschinen, die man ungern ausschaltet. Also ich bin ja auch eher so ein bisschen so der Powerhawk und hab die Kiste gerne erreichbar und greif da gerne mal drauf zu von außen.
Ich mach meinen aus abends.
Ja, mach ich manchmal so, mal so, mal so, aber immer wenn ich ihn ausschalte, bereue ich es dann schon wieder, weil das Ding halt auch irgendwie so ein Backup-Hub ist und gerade wenn ich unterwegs bin mit einem Laptop und ich nehme mir jetzt einen Podcast auf, dann schiebe ich die Aufnahme schon, während der Aufnahme habe ich Bittorrent-Sync laufen es einfach sofort hier auf meinen Mac Pro. Das heißt, wenn mir im Zug danach mein Rechner geklaut wird, die Aufnahme ist da und damit irgendwie potenziell auch schon wieder das Geld für den nächsten. Und das ist so ein Faktor. Jetzt hatte ich allerdings das erste zeichnete sich für mich in einem Gespräch über ein potenzielles, hypothetisches Projekt, was jetzt noch nicht real ist. Vielleicht auch nie real wird, aber was sich mal abgezeichnet hat, konnte ich sehen, dass es vielleicht einen Bedarf gibt für einen neuen Computer. Weil den habe ich derzeit nicht. Ich bin mit meinem ganzen Podcast, also ich bin auch sehr einfach zufrieden mit meinem ganzen Podcast. Ich bin hier mit meinem Setup grundsätzlich. Aber so ein iMac 5K wäre super, wenn du jetzt eine Anwendung hast. Darum ging es in dem Fall, wo hohe Auflösungen und vor allem auch hohe Farbqualität eine große Rolle spielen. Bei Bildern. Also wo so 2560 Pixel in X einfach mal 0 ausreichen. Das ist die Kategorie. Also wo es mal so richtig darum geht, in so Bildmaterial auf eine Art und Weise rein zu zoomen und eine Auflösung und vor allem auch eine Farbtiefe zu bekommen.
Und du meinst, das entsprechende ISO-Display alleine wäre schon zu teuer, sozusagen. Also würde es mit einem iMac...
Na gut, ich meine, wenn du so ein iMac jetzt kaufst, hast du halt irgendwie White-Color-Gamut, hast du halt irgendwie 5.000 Pixel, also da...
Was kostet ein iMac?
Das hab ich mich dann auch gefragt. Hab mich dann irgendwie hingesetzt und hab mir das mal zusammengesetzt und so. Ah ja, hier Basis, Preis und so. Geh mal erstmal im kleinsten Modell, kleinste Modell. Kannst ja noch nicht mal... Kannst ja nicht richtig aufrüsten. Kannst noch nicht mal eine Terabyte SSD rein, so. Und dann klickst du dich da irgendwie dumm und durselig. Du könntest ja gerne mal hier so ein bisschen machen. Das ist nämlich wirklich ein schöner Schock-Effekt. Und du denkst so, ach, kauf ich mir doch einfach ein iMac. Das ist doch so ein billiger Computer.
Ja, das hatte ich auch erst gedacht, tatsächlich.
Also das ist ja, was kann schon passieren, ne? So, dann geht's los. Also ich fang mal jetzt mal gleich hier mit 27 Zoll an. Über was anderes müssen wir jetzt nicht reden. Und da gibt's dann so drei Kategorien, die sich irgendwie auf den ersten Blick nur am Prozessor ein bisschen unterscheiden und sonst irgendwie eigentlich kaum. Aber man kann gleich sagen, du kriegst einfach, wenn ich jetzt davon ausgehe, dass ich da einen Terra SSD drin haben will, weil warum nicht? Kannst du eigentlich gleich mit dem größten Modell losmarschieren. Oder ich glaub, das mittlere Modell, probieren wir mal, mittlere Modell, dann sind wir schon mal bei 2,3. Stell es erstmal fest, statt 3,2 Gigahertz gibt's auch 4 Gigahertz. Kann man auch nehmen. Nur mal 360 Euro extra. Wie die Kisse hat nur 8 GB RAM, geht ja gar nicht. Mein Mac Pro hat 32, bumm, nochmal 720 Euro drauf. Dafür kriegst du einen fucking, ja, aber du kannst ja dann auch nie anders, also, ne, ah, ein Terabyte Fusion Drive, also wie so ein Hybrid zwischen SD und Festplatte. Geh mir aus der Sonne, ich will einen Terabyte Flash. 1080 Euro, dafür kriegst du dann sogar noch eine Magic Mouse, Trackpad anklicken, nochmal 60 Euro. Wo sind wir denn jetzt angekommen? Was kostet der Spaß? 4519 Euro. 4519 Euro. Sag mal, ihr habt's ja wohl nicht alle.
Und jetzt ist das Ding, der Mac Pro, der 2009er oder 5.1er, der hat wahrscheinlich sogar, also für die damalige vergleichbare Konfiguration, jetzt haben wir auf die Zeit gerechnet, wahrscheinlich genauso viel oder mehr gekostet, aber du hättest jetzt sozusagen die letzten Jahre immer noch für kleine Beiträge das Ding sozusagen immer schön aufrüsten können.
Ist das dann aber auch ein Quad-Core?
Du alter dazwischen-Quatscher! Und jetzt hast du so einen iMac, der dann halt die nächsten zwei, drei Jahre so mitmacht und dann...
Ja, da wird schon eine Weile halten auch, aber man kann halt nicht nachrüsten. Nichts mit neuer Grafikkarte reinmachen?
Genau, mein ich ja. Oder CPU tauschen.
Oder CPU tauschen, ja.
Kannst du hier im Kaufprozess auch gleich noch einen Promise-Piggy-Sandalfolz-Race-Szene? 3.5 kriegst du nochmal 24 Terabyte dazu. Also man kann hier echt schon eine Menge Kohle lassen.
Ja, also ich mein wirklich, ok, dann ist das entsprechende NEC oder ISO-Display aber doch schon wahrscheinlich die bessere Option.
Auf jeden Fall ist der iMac 5K, also ich finde, ich verstehe ja, dass da auch eine Menge drin ist. Ich meine, das Ding ist nicht lahm, das Ding hat brillanten Bildschirmen, der alleine sicherlich nochmal so 1000, 1500 Euro wert ist.
Aber ich hätte Angst, wenn ich wüsste, ich muss jetzt hier mit Handbrake irgendwie einen 3-Stunden-Movie irgendwie nach X265 umrechnen und der muss da jetzt mal 10 Stunden irgendwie Full Power machen, da glüht mir doch das Display weg. Da hab ich doch Angst, um meine feinen Pixel da, so heiß wird der. Vor allem, der kann ja auch nicht so prima lüften, weil ist ja alles ein bisschen dünner da. Weißt du, bei dem Mac Pro ist mir das egal. Der pust da einfach so lange raus, bis halt...
Die Gardine waagerecht flattert.
Der Klimawandel abgeschlossen ist. Tja, ist so eine Abwägung. Aber ich finde das irgendwie... Da muss ich noch was tun. Dieser ganze Retina-Klimmbimm. Wie viele Jahre Retina auf Mac haben wir jetzt?
Weiß ich gar nicht.
Seit wann ging das los?
Also ich hab's noch nicht und mein Rechner ist von 2011.
Dann gab's das dann sozusagen auch noch nicht.
Ja, das kam dann Ende 2012 oder irgendwie so ging das, glaube ich, los.
Vier Jahre. Kann hinhauen. Vier Jahre Retina und ich bin immer noch nicht dabei.
Also wobei das Dell-Display, ich mein Pixel, also es ist natürlich nicht Retina, aber ich hab's.
Das hat zweieinhalb tausend, also du hast ein 4K, ist das so?
Nee, nee, das hat zweieinhalb tausend.
Achso, ja, hab ich auch in meinem Apple-Cinema.
Also es ist jetzt auch nicht total furchtbar, unaushaltbar.
Nein, nein, das hab ich ja hier alles überall, aber...
Also ich sag nur, ja so ein ISO-Display 4K ist schon auch nicht billig, 1.400 Euro.
Du bist ja eh nur am zocken.
Nee, ich sag ja für ihn, wenn er jetzt hier so irgendwie krasse Fotobearbeitungen, bei NEC können wir ja auch mal kurz gucken. Das sind ja die anderen Experten.
Ja gut, aber ich meine, also dann will man auch schon so ein 5K-Teil haben.
Na das geht ja nicht, weil es gibt den Standard noch nicht dafür. Apple kann das doch nur machen, weil sozusagen Rechner und Display- und Grafikkarte eine Einheit sind und außerhalb mit Anschlüssen geht das noch nicht.
Ich weiß. Und deswegen ist das irgendwie auch alles für mich auch im Jahr 2016 noch lange kein Thema. Wenn ich jetzt was ausprobieren will, dann suche ich mir vielleicht jemanden, der so einen Teil hat, oder finde eine andere Lösung.
Oder leist dir.
Ist mir einfach zu bestänken.
Aber weißt du, was Apple machen könnte, und es würde so billig sein für die, anstatt dass sie ihre Tonne da für Millionen von Dollar irgendwie in Johnny Ive schieben müssen, damit das Ding schwarz-rund ist, nehmen einfach den alten Mac Pro, machen dann ein neues Motherboard mit einer aktuellen CPU rein, die dann auf diesen vier Festplatten-Ports dann auch SATA 3 anbietet, USB 3 auf die Anschlüsse haut irgendwie, das WLAN und das Bluetooth schon mit dabei hat, und ja, fertig, oder?
Ja, also das hat mich eigentlich auch...
Und da, wo die CD-ROMs sind, können sie von außen Einschübe für 2,5 Zoll SSDs machen.
Das hat mich echt eigentlich auch so bei dieser ganzen Experience so ein bisschen schockiert, dass...
Das habt ihr verlassen?
Ja, also warum?
Das ist so ein bisschen so, du hast eine Freundin verlassen?
Die ist doch so klug und so hübsch.
So eine läuft dir nie wieder vor den Bein. Wenn du wirklich die Frage stellst, Workstation, wie hätt ich's gerne? Also dieses Gerät erfüllt bis auf sein Alter und die damit verbundenen kleinen Einschränkungen alle Anforderungen.
Aber das haben die ja schon mal gemacht, ne? Mit dem X-Serve.
Ja, na gut, also der X-Serve, das ist jetzt ein anderes Thema, würde ich sagen.
Ja, aber der war auch optisch und benutzmäßig.
Also das war eine der geilsten Server, die ich jemals anfassen durfte, ohne Frage. Aber haben sie da jemals Xeon eingebaut noch?
Ja, die gleichen, die wir auch haben, oder eine Stufe davor oder irgendwie so. Aber das ist wie unser 4.1er, aber dafür gibt es halt kein Update auf die neueren. Und ja, das ist dann alles nicht so cool. Aber sonst war das schon auch geile Hardware.
Ja, das schon, aber da hätte ich zum Beispiel weniger. Also ich will ja auch Mac OS benutzen auf dem X-Surf, da hätte ich wahrscheinlich heutzutage BBSD installiert.
Das macht schon keinen Sinn, aber von der Hardware, das war auch eine schicke Sache, aber haben sie einfach eingestellt. Und die haben das auch nicht eingestellt, weil sie da miese fahren, sondern irgendwie, weil das Business so klein ist, dass es sich nicht lohnt. Irgendwie so.
Aber ich mein, dann diesen krassen Weg zu gehen, wir bauen eine Fabrik in den USA, um diese Papiertonne zu bauen und angeblich ja, also ich weiß nicht, vielleicht haben sie es mittlerweile geändert, aber nur für diese Papiertonne, das ist doch auch totaler Wahnsinn. Das ist doch totaler Wahnsinn.
Die müssen aber bestimmt nicht im Akkord arbeiten.
Ja, das glaube ich auch nicht.
Irgendwie müssen die das auf jeden Fall alles mal ein bisschen mehr affordable machen.
Also ich hab auch das Gefühl, der Mac Pro, ich hab ja zu Hause so einen alten Cube stehen.
Das ist der Cube.
Das ist original der Cube. Sieht geil aus und so, aber... Ja, hab ich aus der Uni abgestaubt.
Ach, das Teil aus der Uni?
Na, die hatten ja mehrere.
Das hab ich so gehasst.
Ich hab den auch nur einmal gebootet bisher.
Ich hab den so gehasst.
Ja, ich find den...
Der ist so misslungen. Das ist so dermaßen so...
Leucht überhaupt schon ein USX drauf?
Ja, das ist diese Puckmaus irgendwie.
Aber der kam 2001 raus, oder? Oder 2000, oder wann kam der raus?
Da ist ein USX drauf.
Das war dann das erste und das zweite, und dann wahrscheinlich schon nicht mehr.
Ja, kann sein. Ich mein, ich hab den nur aus... Wir können ja mal Mac Tracker mal gucken.
Aus nostalgischen Gründen und so.
Scheiße!
Der war scheiße!
Der war schon tausendmal. Das war einfach wirklich so... Da war einfach das Wort Design einfach verwechselt worden mit Optik, ne? Klar, durchsichtiger, Würfel, bla bla bla, alles ganz hübsch.
Das Durchsichtige war auch kraftlastig und war total schnell verkratzt, oder?
Ja, und dann vor allem diese ganze Kabelgeschwäre, was da unten raus kam, und wenn du da mal an irgendwas raus wolltest, und von allen ging er dann immer so hin, so oh, ist das der neue Cube, darf ich ihn mal...
Dann war er gleich ausgeschaltet, weil da oben dieser Touch... Mac OS 10.4 10.4.11 war das Maximum OS.
War das auch das letzte Powerbit? Nee, das Firma konnte auch noch Powerbit sehen, ja gut.
Ja, wie gesagt, also der Mac Pro jetzt, der erinnert mich auch ganz stark. Da dran natürlich ist der...
Die Tonne meinste.
Meinste, jetzt, guter Punkt, ne? Jetzt sind wir ja im Prinzip auch schon fast am Ende, glaube ich. Es steht ja jetzt noch ein Event an. Sie werden dieses Jahr noch was, also ob sie ein Event draus machen, weiß ich nicht, aber sie werden das Mac-Line ab, werden sie nochmal.
Ich denke auch, aber sie machen kein Event draus. Das hatten sie bisher noch nicht gemacht. Ich hab ja eigentlich vermutet, dass das gestern passiert.
Kann ich mir aber nicht vorstellen, dass sie dann ein neues MacBook Pro mit diesem Touch-Ding kommentarlos einfach mit einem Apple-Store-Appel draus machen.
Man kann nur hoffen, dass das mit diesem Touch-Ding nicht kommt.
Du hast doch gesehen, wie akkurat mittlerweile die Gerüchteküche wieder geworden ist. Das ist doch wie vor 15 Jahren. Man kann von nichts anderem ausgehen. Es gibt ja jetzt auch schon die ersten Hinweise in den US-Ten, in Sierra. Diese Touchbar ist real. Es gibt Trademark-Anwendungen. Die einzige Frage, die ich beantwortet haben möchte, ist, wandert die Escape-Taste auf die Tastatur? Oder killen Sie die Escape-Taste? Weil Apple, wenn ihr die Escape-Taste auf so einen Scheiß-Touchbar legt, dann sind wir einfach geschiedene Leute, die das nicht machen, die das nicht machen, dann gehe ich einfach mental einen anderen Weg.
Aber auch nur mental.
Ansonsten noch nicht gleich.
Dann wird Second Mac mein neues Zuhause.
Dann lebe ich einfach im Jahr 2009 weiter, bis in eine Ewigkeit, bis hier irgendwie neuen, keine Ahnung, wer auch immer dafür verantwortlich ist.
Ja, aber der Space, da können wir doch irgendwie noch 3mm Batterie in den Platz einbauen, wo die Escape-Taste war.
Da gibt es einen Shit-Sonder als Klinkenstecker an Scheißzeichen.
Ich glaube nicht, die meisten nutzen noch die... Also normale Leute brauchen auch die Escape-Taste gar nicht, oder?
Auf dieser Keynote haben sie dieses Eyework gezeigt. Und dann tippte sie so ein bisschen rum und so. Und dann meinte sie dann irgendwann, und dann drücke ich Escape und dann passiert das und das. Und da dachte ich mir so, alles klar, ihr drückt Escape, diese Taste ist wichtig. Ihr könnt mir ja wohl nicht erzählen, dass euer frisches Produkt, was ihr gerade auf eurer grandiosen Keynote hier weltweit durch die Gegend gestreamt habt, wo mehr Leute zuschauen als bei Olympia, dass diese Taste dann schon wieder defunkt sein soll, ein Monat später, wenn ihr eure neuen Büchsen rausbringt.
Ich bin gespannt, aber ich kann mir nicht vorstellen, dass sie da oben eine Leiste machen und daneben noch eine normale Taste belassen.
Nein, nein, sie sollen diese komische Carre-Grad-Taste gegen Escape austauschen.
Die da drunter, ja?
Ja, weil die brauch ich da jetzt wirklich nicht. Also ich meine, da hängt die nicht von ab.
Die brauch ich selten.
Da einfach Escape. Ich hab auch gar nichts gegen eine große Escape-Taste. Finde ich vollkommen okay. Aber Carre-Grad auf der deutschen Tastatur, ich glaub auf der amerikanischen, sind da die Akzente?
Nee, also ich hab ja US, hatten wir ja schon mal, US International. Also ich hab hier auch ein deutsches auf dem Dings, aber gemapt US. Warte, ich guck mal, was da gerade bei US International ist. Das Layout der Sieger sozusagen.
Ich weiß nicht, ob die das da oben mapen.
Da, was ist da? Da ist Paragrafzeichen auch nicht so wichtig.
Ich befürchte, sie lassen das da oben in diesem Touchding drin.
Paragrafzeichen, ich mein für so ein scheiß Paragrafzeichen opferten wir noch keine Escape-Tasen.
Nee, aber... Was ist auf Shift? Dieses Plusminus zusammen.
Das Plusminus, da hat noch nie jemand eingegeben.
Ja, das würde ich auch behaupten.
Ja, was für eine sinnlose Funktion. Also Apple, wenn ihr da Escape drauflegt, dann ist alles gut, ja? Dann können wir auch wieder secern.
Oder wenn wir das remappen dürfen. Das wäre auch okay noch.
Aber das ist ja nicht mehr die obere Ecke, die man blind so schnell erwischt. Weil man kann sich ja da so...
Ja, wenn er so ein Touchbar ist, ist das wieder die obere Ecke.
Ja, aber du kannst ja das Touchbar nicht zum Orientieren benutzen, weil da hast du es ja gleich getouched.
Nein, aber du kannst die Tasse selber zum Orientieren benutzen. Wieso, jetzt ist doch auch die Tasse links oben.
Ja, aber jetzt kann ich sie noch erfühlen, ohne dass ich sie drücke. Wenn da dieses Touch-Ding ist, dann wenn ich dann da rumfühle, wo welche Tasse ist, dann hab ich ja gleich gedrückt.
Das ist übrigens auch nochmal ein ganz interessanter Punkt, dass diese Tastatur eigentlich so eine schöne fummelfreundliche Bereich ist. Da kannst du dich so richtig schön mit deinem ganzen Schweiß, mit deinen ganzen Körpersäften einfach so ausbreiten, ohne irgendwelche Konsequenzen zu fürchten. Aber wenn er jetzt wieder so eine Touch-Hölle lauert, dann bist du da, dann musst du dich, dann musst du wirklich, das ist doch scheiße.
Ich hoffe, dass sie das Gerücht in die Menge gestreut haben, um zu sehen, wie die Reaktionen sind.
Man will da einfach russchreien.
Wir haben die Escape-Taste vergessen und dann haben sie das Projekt vielleicht wieder eingestampft.
Oh man, ich hab die Escape-Taste geschrubbt.
Oder das war wirklich nur ein Mock-Up, weil irgendwelche PC-Lenovo's irgendwie so eine komische Leiste haben, so halbschick, also auch nicht so richtig. Also das sind zwar Zeichen, die beleuchtet werden, aber es sind immer die gleichen Zeichen.
Also ich hoffe, dass wenn sie dieses Ding bringen, dass sie da wirklich irgendwas ganz, ganz, ganz, ganz grandioses irgendwie abfeiern. Also wenn sie da nicht wirklich so einen Feature aus dem Käfig lassen, wo alle nur sagen so, darauf hab ich das Leben gewartet, dann sorry.
Was auch geil wäre es, wenn Apple für die alten Mac Pros ein Upgrade-Kit rausbringt einfach, weil den Rechner hab ich ja schon.
Ich brauch nur das Board.
Ja, eigentlich schon, eigentlich schon.
Genau, das wär geil so. Beim Apple Store gibt's auch rechts oben so einen Advanced-Button und dann wechselt sich alles. Dann gibt's nicht mehr diese shiny, shiny Seiten, sondern alles wird nur noch in HTML.
Weißt du, die wollen da eigentlich auch auf Öko machen und Bio und nicht irgendwie Alu und weiß nicht, was alle machen. Hab ich alles schon, braucht man nicht wegschmeißen, sondern ich brauch nur das Upgrade-Kit.
Ja, eigentlich aber ganz ehrlich, das, was diesen MacPro ja so charmant im Inneren und elegant aussehen lässt, ist ja dieses Board, weil alles halt da sich so auf dieses Board rauf slidet quasi, deswegen sind ja da keine Kabel.
Wie groß das ist. Ich meine, wenn du dir die aktuelle Integrationstechnik nimmst von Apple, was du da alles drauf kriegen könntest, da kriegst du nicht nur einen Rechner drauf, da kriegst du einen Rechenzentrum drauf.
Ja, das stimmt allerdings.
Da kannst du irgendwie so einen Array von Arm-Prozessoren, deine normalen Xeon-CPUs und dann switchst du auch so hin und her.
Ich möchte mir gerne so sechs A12-Prozessoren irgendwie auf dieses Mainboard draufkrennen. Das wird dann so ein 3D-Drucker, irgendwie in dem Copyshop um die Ecke gedruckt. Und dann wirft man sich das einfach in seine Büchse rein.
Also wirklich meine größte Frage, was Apple jetzt so macht mit einem ihrer Produkte, ist wirklich der Mac Pro. Ob sie bei der Papiertonne bleiben und da noch iterieren oder ob das wie bei dem Cube? Oder bei dem Watch.
Dass sie einfach sagen, hat nicht funktioniert.
Der Watch?
Naja, mit dem User-Interface. Das ist das beste Vergleich.
Dass sie auch mal einen Schritt wieder zurück machen.
Dass sie einfach sagen, ja okay, geile Lüfter, aber ich glaub's nicht.
Das vermute leider auch nicht.
Das wird es definitiv nicht geben, ob sie die Tonne weitermachen. Also wenn da sie mal einen Schritt zurückgehen und dann der nächste quadratische Mac Pro mit Schiebezeug irgendwie kommt oder Sachen zum Wechseln oder wenigstens PCI Slots. Also das reicht ja. Du musst ja nicht mal eine tauschbare CPU sein. Das machen sie wahrscheinlich nicht nochmal. Es wundert mich sowieso, warum die das gemacht haben. Also ich meine, eine userwechselbare CPU. Ja, also ist total geil. Aber warum Apple das gemacht hat, wenn sie auch gar keine Upgrades an CPU verkaufen. Also es war ja nur, damit die da besser den Rechner variabler zusammenschrauben können, um die dann zu verkaufen, aber es gab ja nie.
Da waren halt einfach ein paar korrekte Leute bei Apple, die danach wahrscheinlich gefeuert wurden.
Ganz früher, diese Power-PCs waren ja auch schon so Karten zum Wechseln. Ja.
Als ich so nach Mac Pro so ein bisschen geguckt hab und da hab ich auch so ein paar Ersatzteile gefunden, wo du halt auch leere Mac, also die leeren Mac Pro Chassis sozusagen bekommst, diese großen Gehäuse und so und wirklich jedes einzelne Ersatzteil, dann bin ich auch über Google, kam so ein Result Kickstarter, Mac Pro, Chassis und so weiter und ich dachte so, gibt's einen Kickstarter, was sozusagen, ne, so... Und so weiter und dann war das aber, die haben quasi den Papiertonn, das Papiertonn Chassis und so als Kickstarter-Project für deinen... Und ich dachte, aber da dachte ich mir, weißt du, ein neues Board, Kickstarter-Project, ich meine...
Ja, aber dann hättest du ja einen Hackentosch und dann musst du dir ja rumfummeln und basteln und das ist ja alles, ne?
Ich will pimpen und ich bastel. Sagt. Bastelst du noch oder pimst du schon?
Es ist ja ein bisschen gemeint, ich meine, wir müssen ja... Also ich lasse die Finger ja deswegen davon, wann Apple aktiv was dagegen tut, dass man einen PC benutzt. Also ist ja schon... Und das ist noch der Witz, die Leute, die so einen Hackentosch haben, die haben die fette aktuelle CPU und haben irgendwie fette Grafikkarten, weil sie sich beim booten dann nicht drum kümmern müssen, weil da trotzdem Bootscreen kommt und so. Das heißt, die Scheiße mit dem Hackentosch haben die fettesten Macs.
Aber die meisten Kabel auch.
Ja, das ist dann glaube ich auch mal echt egal.
Das machst du dann zu und dann ist gut.
Ja, das Gelddoppelte Performance ist schon wirklich echt ein bisschen unruhigend. Ja gut, ich meine du hast natürlich dann auch nur das und du hast vieles auch nicht. Also du hast halt, du kriegst ja schon mehr irgendwie in so einem Mac.
Wie jetzt?
Ja, so Handoff und diese ganzen Detailsachen.
Der geht ja auch nicht bei unseren Kisten, weil Apple das nicht supportet.
Ja, aber das geht natürlich. Bei meinem Mac Pro geht das natürlich sehr wohl.
Bei deinem Mac Pro geht das?
Nein, beim neuen Mac Pro. Das ist natürlich alles irgendwie aktuell.
Von dieser Samsung-SSD gibt es übrigens die 960 Pro.
Die gibt es dann auch in Tera oder was?
Die gibt es, glaube ich, auch in Tera. Die kommt aber wohl jetzt erst. Da musst du mal googeln. Es gibt auch eine 961. Also da muss man sich mal ein bisschen durchklicken. Da gibt es irgendwie Sachen.
Fühlt sich eh was. Jetzt gibt es ja auch schon so, was war das, 4TB SSD und so.
Letztens kam einer im Club mit einer normalen Festplatte, zweieinhalb Zoll, sieben Millimeter hoch, also die schmale Bauhöhe. Also wirklich schmal, nicht neun Millimeter, sondern sieben, mit zwei Terabyte drauf.
Das ist das C.
Nee, normale Spinning Rust, aber in sieben Millimeter, zwei Terabyte. Das ist schon...
Ja, es ist komisch, dass sie immer noch so gut mithalten können.
Also wenn man viel storage braucht, kommt man an normalen Platten noch nicht vorbei, finde ich. Also schon preislich sowieso nicht.
Ich hoffe nicht mehr lange.
Ja, das doch, die machen schon noch eine Weile mit. Also...
Na, dass sie so problemlos skalieren können, ist mir ehrlich gesagt immer noch ein Rätsel. Ich meine, die müssten doch auch langsam auf ihre physikalische Grenze kommen.
Na, denen fällt halt immer wieder was Neues ein.
Da werden die Bits plötzlich vertikal gespeichert.
Ja, das ist ja schon alt.
Und jetzt noch dieses, was ich schon ein paar Sende vorher erzählt hab, dieses... wie heißt das? Wie heißen die Dachziegel? Auf Englisch? Irgendwas mit S, C, S, H? Naja, dieses Recording, was wie die Dachziegel heißen. S, M, R?
Schingel?
Schingel Magnetic Recording, genau, wo halt die Spuren immer so halb über die davor geschrieben wird, ohne dass die davor verschwindet, aber dadurch sparen sie nochmal Platz und können wesentlich mehr irgendwie schreiben. Ist aber halt zum Nachträglich drüber schreiben nicht so cool, weil man muss die ganzen Spuren neu schreiben und so, aber da machen die auch gerade und tun und basteln. Und dann dieses irgendwie Festblatt mit Helium-Füllung und der ganze Spielkram, damit die auch weniger Strom brauchen beim Drehen und all sowas.
Das ist ja der Wahnsinn!
Ja, genau, weil sie weniger Luftwiderstand haben, so war das.
Die sollen einfach mal diesen ganzen SSD-Mumpitz irgendwie voranbringen.
Ja, aber Festplatten sind halt nicht so nicht so Vapor-mäßig wie... Da gab es einen schönen Kongress-Talk zum Thema Flash-Speicher, wo als Einleitung davon gesprochen wird, wie einem eigentlich von diesen SSDs oder USB-Sticks oder allen möglichen Flash-Speichern eigentlich vorgegaukelt wird, dass das ein permanenter Speicher wäre. Und was da eigentlich die ganze Zeit...
Achso, der Vortrag von Bunny.
Was da die ganze Zeit im Hintergrund passiert, um dir dieses Gefühl zu geben, deine Daten wären sicher.
Ja gut, aber da geht es um diese billigen SD-Karten-Sticks.
Ja, aber das ist ja trotz alledem...
Ist mir egal, wenn die tonnenweise meine Bits fressen, dann ist gut. Ja, ich meine, du kannst dir bei Festplatten mittlerweile auch nichts mehr sicher sein. Da ist auch irgendwie so eine softe Logik dazwischen, die irgendwie allerlei Voodoo macht und kaputte Blöcke ausblendet.
Ich finde Festplatten halten ewig.
Naja, also die sind da schon ganz gut unterwegs.
Also zumindest die Serverplatten. Ich hab wirklich etliche...
Die sollen jetzt einfach mal ein paar Durchbrüche feiern. Wo ist das Problem? Einfach verdoppeln, jedes Jahr, fertig, ist die lauber.
Ja, machen sie ja auch. Gibt's ja dieses 3D-Nand oder wie es heißt, und da geht's ja schon ordentlich ab gerade.
Ist noch teuer halt.
Ja, es kommt alles noch runter. Aber hier, was ich noch hab.
Spitz noch mal Stingel.
Hab ich dem Hucke hier auch schon gesagt. Und was ich bei dir da auch gesehen hab, Timme, du hast deine Giga-Transactions noch bei 2,5. Das müssen wir mal noch mal fixen, ne? Was hab ich? Deine Giga-Transactions von deiner Grafikrate sind bei 2,5. 2,5 Giga-Transactions pro Sekunde. Und wenn man da so Widerstand von deiner hast du vorhin in deinem About das Ding in der Hand, da konnte ich das sehen, du hattest das, glaube ich, auf dem großen Bildschirm. Und wenn man einen Widerstand auslötet, nämlich R17, dann geht das auf hier ganz unten, da steht es da, Link Speed, siehst du, ganz ganz unten. Genau, ja. Genau, das kann man auf 5 hochschrauben, wenn man da den R17 auslötet. Der ist so klein, du musst den tatsächlich mit der Lupe suchen und selbst dann hat man Schwierigkeiten, weil das diese ganz kleine...
Auslötet und dann?
Lässt den einfach weg.
Und dann?
Und dann hast du 5. Hat doch so ein Typ rausgefunden. Ich weiß nicht, wie die das machen. Ich glaube, die Karte hat so Erkenn-Bits halt irgendwie und das wird halt über diese Widerstände geregelt. Also entweder ist die Leitung sozusagen on oder off oder wie auch immer.
Dann ist meine Grafikkarte doppelt so schnell. Ein Bottleneck ist weniger.
Also du hast da nicht wirklich viel so davon. Aber weißt du, wir sind hier bei My Mac und da holt man halt raus, was geht.
Widerstand ist zwecklos.
Ist nicht so einfach, weil es wirklich fucking klein ist. Also man muss da wirklich, also ich weiß nicht, ob ich ihn mit der Lupe sogar ausgelötet habe. Also das ist so krass, wie klein diese Widerstände sind. Aber wenn man den wegmacht, dann hat man das auch erledigt.
So, jetzt nochmal das Jingle zum Abfeiern.
Zum Ausklaren.
Ich bin jetzt auch dabei.
So, jetzt haben wir noch einen Stellengesuch.
Genau, jetzt haben schon so viele Leute davon gelesen. Ich hab ja heute auch getwittert.
Ich hab mir ja auch gleich bei Huckeln eine zähere Grafikkarte hatte als ich.
Ich dachte mal, weil, weißt du so, hier Wuga, für die ich ja gearbeitet hab, die haben gerade, denen geht es nicht so gut, und die haben mal so einen ganzen Stapel Leute entlassen. Und ich war denen jetzt mittlerweile auch zu teuer, aber das lag auch vor allen Dingen daran, dass die ihren Fokus so ein bisschen geändert haben. Und für mich gab es nicht mehr viel zu tun, außer Beschäftigungstherapie. Ich hab schon die letzte Woche eigentlich auch nur YouTube-Videos geguckt, weil es wirklich nichts zu tun gab, und hab tatsächlich mit dem Gedanken gespielt, ich geh mal zum Chef und sag, Motivation ist bei Null, was macht man da? Da kamen sie mir aber zuvor, und dann gab es so eine E-Mail, und jetzt hab ich drei Monate bezahlt, einen Urlaub plus Abfindung, darf einen ganzen Stapel irgendwie noch Sachen weiter benutzen. Alles supi, also ich hab jetzt das erste Mal in meinem Leben wirklich bezahlt, Freizeit, das ist total angenehm. Aber früher oder später suche ich halt natürlich schon mal eine weitere Beschäftigung, weil so gut hab ich bei VUGA jetzt auch nicht verdient, dass ich mich schon zur Ruhe setzen könnte.
Weige denn, dass du deine Ausgabenkontrolle schon...
Genau, das Gear Acquisition Syndrome ist ja noch weiter am Laufen, das hat von der Kündigung noch nichts mitbekommen. Ja, und auf Arbeitslosengeld hab ich dann im Dezember auch keinen Bock. Und natürlich, da gab's gleich einen Artikel dazu, zu dieser Entlassungswelle da bei VUGA irgendwo, Gründer, Magazin, was auch immer. Und seitdem krieg ich auf LinkedIn halt einfach jeden Tag irgendwie zig irgendwelche Mails von Startups mit Ideen, wo eine bekloppter ist als der Name des nächsten Startups. Also wirklich, was wir letztens schon besprochen haben, hatten so die lösen...
Join Improverer.
Ja, die Probleme versuchen zu lösen, die fast keiner hat. Na ja, und eigentlich hab ich alle meine Jobs immer durch irgendwelche Freunde oder Bekannte bekommen bisher. Und ich dachte mir, ok, bevor ich jetzt da auf LinkedIn und mit Headhuntern telefoniere oder was auch immer, schreib ich mal so einen kleinen Blogpost und sag mal Bescheid, falls so in meiner erweiterten Social Bubble irgendjemand gerade sucht und so weiter. Und ist unten auch hier so CV und so ein bisschen mal zusammengeschrieben, was ich so gemacht hab. Und lass es jetzt so entspannt auf mich zukommen. Ich hatte jetzt auch schon so ein, zwei Mittagessen mit Leuten, die interessiert waren, aber ich dachte mir, wenn man schon drei Monate Zeit hat zur entspannten Suche, dann mach ich es mal so rum, anstatt mit diesen Herren und Damen Headhuntern zu verhandeln. Ja, aber es ist auf jeden Fall echt merkwürdig, weil die haben halt so gesagt, ja, sorry, läuft nicht so gut, ihr 41, ihr könnt jetzt einfach auch nach Hause gehen, müsst nicht mehr herkommen, Kündigungsfrist, volles Gehalt, plus noch ein bisschen Bonbons oben drauf. Und dann wachst du halt am nächsten Tag so auf, siehst alles so in deinem Umfeld normal, sich verhalten, Leute, Nachbarn gehen zur Arbeit, Leute wandern auf und ab die Straße, gehen zur Bäckerei, ich stehe so auf. Ich glaube, ich mach jetzt erstmal ein paar Zombies platt.
Und dann lege ich mich vielleicht nochmal hin.
War schon auch echt mal ein witziger Wechsel.
Ich mach das ja immer andersrum. Wie rum? Ich wach morgens auf und dann denke ich, ich lege mich nochmal hin und dann gehe ich Zombies killen.
Du gehst doch wahrscheinlich sowieso erst ins Bett, weil die anderen zur Arbeit anfangen zu geben.
Ja, ich will mir morgens noch Brötchen vor dem Schlafen gehen.
Falls es da draußen irgendwelche Leute gibt, die vergleichsweise erfahrende Backend-Entwickler brauchen, in Berlin, dann ist das doch mal bescheid.
Die kommen ja alle nach Berlin. London ist ja jetzt nix mehr.
Es gibt aber noch andere Städte.
Du schreibst ja da irgendwie, du möchtest gerne was, was meaningful ist, damit du nicht in so einem Free-2-Play-Casual irgendwie Befehl führen deine Kinder zum teifenden Candy. Was ist denn meaningful? Was könnte meaningful sein? Fintech ist jetzt vielleicht nicht gerade, oder?
Ich muss sagen...
Auch ein Bitcoin-Unternehmen?
Moralisch, ethisch muss ich sagen, war ich jetzt bei diesen Free-To-Play-Games eh so ein bisschen an der Grenze. Weil, also hätte jetzt unser Chef irgendwann gesagt, wir machen jetzt auch so Casino Games, dann hätte ich glaube ich auch schon vorher mal...
Die Reißleine gezogen.
Ja, das war sozusagen so der schmale Grad dazwischen, aber letztendlich jetzt so, wie sich der Markt entwickelt hat, sind das alles nur Slot-Machines, die irgendwie so ein Schlumpfbären-Themen kriegen und es eigentlich nur darum geht, möglichst effizient den Leuten das Geld aus der Tasche zu ziehen, wobei natürlich manche Spiele durchaus auch noch Spaß machen dabei.
Wie lange könntest du denn jetzt problemlos überleben?
Naja, ich kriege ja den Maximalsatz RLG 1 noch.
Wir haben ja einfach nur eine Zeit. Ein Jahr locker, sodass du danach auch immer noch Zeit hast, dir einen anderen Job zu suchen.
Reis um die Welt, ich sag's dir.
Reis um die Welt, ich sag's dir. Oder noch besser, geh doch irgendwie in den Südpazifik und mach Admin auf Sea Shepherd. Das ist doch eine Gelegenheit, die man nutzen muss. Dieser Grad an Freiheit, dieses jetzt keine Bindung, noch ein bisschen Kohle, ich bin jung und brauche das Geld nicht unbedingt. Und dann kann man, an der Stelle kannst du mal dem Wort meaningful machen, meaning zu schieben. Weil was du da an Erfahrung gesammelt bekommst und auch einfach an Lebensqualität eingesammelt bekommst, das kann ja kein scheiß Start-up mit irgendwie vollkommen verrohene, piepelten Hirnen mit irgendwie Weltdominanz-Fantasien und so weiter jemals reinbringen. Ich meine, die haben doch alle einen Schaden.
Ja, sagen wir mal 95 Prozent auf jeden Fall. Also ich habe auch schon einiges gelesen und gehört, wo ich also gar nicht genug Hände hatte für die Face Palms, die ich da auspielen wollte. Aber, also parallel habe ich jetzt ja vor, die Zeit zu nutzen, schon mal für einen Segelschein. Ich dachte mir auch so als Alternativplan, die Meeresspiegel steigen, Segellehrer wäre auch noch gut, Segelboot, Zukunftstechnologie, ja. Irgendwann am Fernsehturm mit Boot festmachen, hat auch was. Aber das wäre so im Sinne Lebensqualität und da so draußen und um die Welt, das wäre eigentlich der optimale Modus dann, ja.
Was ist wenn Apple anruft?
Was sollen die von mir wollen? Ja, eigentlich, ich habe auch so, ich will eigentlich auch nicht unbedingt so mega große Firmen, also Amazon oder was auch immer, das ist mir eigentlich schon ein bisschen zu fett. Netflix hätte ich ganz gut gefunden, aber die wollen, dass man nach Amsterdam zieht. Habe ich nicht so Bock drauf. Aber die benutzen halt FreeBSD und machen so...
Geilen Scheiß...
.noch viel selber. Ja, also eigentlich meaningful, also wenn ich es mir glaube ich komplett ausruhen soll, würde, welches Feld ich beackern würde wollen, dann wäre es glaube ich tatsächlich irgendwas mit Bildung. Irgendwas, was die Menschen weiterbringt, weil ich mache diesen Uni-Kurs immer noch seit acht Jahren mittlerweile oder neun.
Alter, vermiet deine Scheißwohnung und bewege deinen Arsch ein halbes Jahr irgendwie nach Südamerika oder was weiß ich wohin. Mal ehrlich.
Ja, ist auch ein Gedanke.
Auf jeden Fall südliche Erdkugel. Und zwar süden auch. Weil man möglichst weit weg ist von zu Hause. Und wenn man möglichst weit weg ist von zu Hause, merkt man erst mal, was wichtig ist. Was hier auch cool ist irgendwie so. Und du bist auch so gelöst, dass irgendwie, weil am Anfang ist die Jahr und dann will ich auch irgendwann bestimmt wieder nach Hause und hier und da. Und man fliegt ja teilweise auch nicht so gern. Aber wenn du so weit weg bist, dann kommst du in so ein heute bin ich hier und morgen bin ich da Modus. Das stört dann auch alles gar nicht mehr. Und man wird auch sehr leicht vom Gepäck, weil man braucht gar nicht so viel.
Dann wird einem die Sachen egal und dann merkt man auch, was wirklich, also dann merkt man auf einmal, was ist mir wichtig, was vermisst du? Vermisst du dein Mac Pro? Internet, Freak Show, ja klar.
Vermisst du deine Freunde? Wen vermisst du, wen nicht?
Klar kann sein, vielleicht ist dir der Scheiß Podcast irgendwie total egal, aber vielleicht ist es auch das Wichtigste an dem du teilgenommen hast. Weil das ist das Einzige, was deine Mentalität überhaupt sichergestellt hat.
Na ja, also sagen wir mal so, ist auf jeden Fall auch eine Option. Allerdings würde ich auch sagen, dass ich vergleichsweise so schon geerdet bin, dass diese Fragen ich gar nicht so groß beantworten müsste. Aber ist auf jeden Fall auch ein Gedanke. Wie gesagt, ich bin, also I'm looking for a new job heißt nicht I'm desperately searching.
Ja klar schon, ich hab's ja schon verstanden. Deswegen meine ich ja gerade, also diese Freiräume, weil diese Freiräume sind mehr wert. Also ich hatte auch so ein paar Zeiten in meinem Leben, wo ich jetzt im Rückblick sagen würde, so Alter, warum hast du dich nicht auf den Weg gemacht? Ich meine, teilweise hab ich's getan, teilweise hab ich's aber auch einfach sträblich missachtet und es sind auch teilweise Zeiten, die ich jetzt so überhaupt nicht repliziert bekomme, Alter, Fitness und von daher, ähm, ich hab ja... Du kannst gerne mal Pause machen, für drei Monate zumindest mal.
Ich hab letztens, äh, als es auch so darum ging, irgendwie, äh, jetzt hier, ähm, für, na wie soll ich sagen, also mir ist so ein Spruch irgendwie eingefallen, Zeit ist Geld, aber Geld ist nicht Zeit, also, ähm, du kannst, ne, also du verkaufst Lebenszeit sozusagen an Arbeitgeber oder was auch immer, aber wenn dir jemand Geld gibt, kannst du das nicht wieder in Zeit umwandeln, also das geht sozusagen, das geht nur in eine Richtung, das Thema, und jetzt hab ich natürlich gerade quasi beides Geld und Zeit, das ist die ideale Mischung, aber genau was du sagst, also wenn du Zeit hast, das kann man halt nicht aufwägen, außer du entscheidest dich aktiv dafür, sie zu verkaufen.
Ja, ich meine, mach deinen scheiß Segelschein, kauf dir so ein Segelboot, setz dich da in Südamerika auf das Teil drauf und guck durch die Gegend. Ich kenn ein paar Leute, die machen das, und das ist irgendwie nicht das schlechteste Ding. Muss ja nicht der komplette Lebensinhalt bleiben. Aber meaningful ist definitiv.
Und unterwegs kannst du sogar auch noch arbeiten.
Da kann man sich dran gewöhnen.
Also Segellehrer wäre da schon, oder so, in dem Bereich, aber mit Computern unterwegs arbeiten.
Also ob ein App-Developer jetzt irgendwie in Berlin in einer Start-up-Klitsche sitzt oder in Amerika auf dem Boot.
Das ist auf jeden Fall schon eine ganz klare Einschränkung. Frontend dat mach ich nicht. Bin der Dundead.
Sagt der alte Designer.
Abgehakt, genau.
So sag ich das auch nichts mehr, wo mir einer sagt, ich hab den Button aber gerne da.
Na ja, ich wollte es nochmal so in die Runde werfen, falls vielleicht findet sich ja und die Sterne und so weiter und alles kommt zusammen und alles ist super.
Ich könnte mir durchaus vorstellen, dass in unserem Hörerkreis die Leute auf lustige Ideen kommen. Das ist ja auch so mein Rettungsanker, wenn mir nichts mehr einfällt. Da frage ich meine Hörer. Die kommen immer auf so lustige Ideen, da kommt bestimmt was bei raus.
Also, falls ihr auch sonst noch Reiseplanungsideen habt, gerne der Link zu diesem Tweet bzw. dem Blogpost und alles Weitere ist bestimmt in den Show-Notes.
Ja, wir haben noch Hörer around the clock. Ich meine, wenn du sagst, irgendwie sechs Monate unterwegs, dann kriegst du wahrscheinlich für jedes Scheißland irgendwo auch in dieser Stadt eine Hütte.
Das ist natürlich auch eine Variante. Schauen wir mal. Also, genau, dann ist jetzt aber auch diese Themenkarte schon fertig.
Absolut. Dann haben wir auch alle durch, oder?
Ich glaube, ja.
Oder, Dennis? Meinst haben wir unsere vier Stunden sogar wieder fast voll bekommen. Dann, was sagt Schubacker dazu? Ja, denke ich auch. Von daher können wir das Ganze irgendwie abschließen, oder? So Leute, war Spaßlich mit euch. Ihr wisst jetzt alles zum Thema iPhone und so. Dann können wir nächstes Mal wieder ordentlich schweigen. Viel Spaß bei den ganzen Updates, Upgrades und was sonst noch ansteht. Und wir sagen Tschüss, ne?
Tschüssi!